Our screens,
let's fucking talk like people.
Man,
let's do this.
Ah,
we're allowed you motherfuckers.
We're live.
Happy Birthday Joe.
Thank you very much.
Brian.
Happy Birthday.
Whenever you're less birthday was
athlete.
I missed it.
Yeah.
I don't like it anymore.
Once you hit 30 it's not cool anymore,
but when you hit 42,
it's just like.
I'm like looking at every time somebody
dies,
I'm like,
how old are they?
40 eight on my gut.
Well,
he is fatter than me,
so I'm good.
Yeah.
I was looking at this,
um,
someone's post on instagram.
Okay.
Like a friend of a friend.
I went instagram hopping.
You know how you go from one person's
page?
You see someone comments?
Something funny.
Oh,
that guy got to say.
And you go to his page and uh,
it was a guy talking about his wife's
brother had died and he had been
suffering with.
Is it you've battled his demons?
Was the quote
six?
I was like,
oh Jesus Christ.
40 six.
Like people are just fucking dying.
Yeah.
The ones that get me the worst,
it's the ones that like,
he just died in his sleep.
Oh yeah,
man.
Patton,
Oswalt's wife.
Yeah.
Did it ever come out?
What happened to her or do not know?
I do not know.
So sad.
But you know,
we all,
uh,
we all will go.
Allegedly Bert Kreischer doesn't believe
it for a car.
She goes,
I don't think we are.
I go,
what do you mean proofread on?
You want me to kill you?
Like what do you want me to do?
We haven't previewed die.
I know people,
they're not around anymore.
They,
they,
they died.
So my,
as opposed to just pretend they're not
just not in this space,
but they're in another space and in that
space I'm there too.
And they went through a portal or what?
We had them on a kill Tony a couple days
ago and he was on this like weird pill.
He took this weird pill and he says that
he's like,
he fucks with my blood pressure though.
Like if I laugh too hard I'll just faint
and pass out.
It's happened three times already so I
might pass it.
I'm like,
wait,
you're going,
you shouldn't not be famous.
Hey,
your brain is shutting off.
Your brain is like too much.
We're done.
Funk.
Oh,
you know,
they say that's what happened to Hillary
Clinton,
that she blacked out.
She fainted and hit her head in 2012.
There's all these concerns that people
have.
I don't know if they're there.
They're founded in any fact,
but apparently the.
The real incident did happen that she
fell down.
She,
she blacked out and fell down and hit
her head and had a clot,
which can be pretty serious,
but there's an of course because of
that,
there's people that are making all these
crazy videos speculating that she has
brain damage and she's out of her mind
that she's like super unhealthy.
Yeah.
Like there's.
See they'd taken these compilations of
her,
you know,
look,
she's doing hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of fucking
interviews like this where people are
talking to her and
you know,
it's,
it probably becomes mind numbing after
a.
It looks like she's having fun to me.
She's laughing,
she's bombed her head up and down and
they're saying that she's acting
bizarre.
I think she's a person who's dealing
with massive,
massive amounts of stress.
I mean,
I'm not necessarily a big fan of what
she represents other than I think it's
Kinda cool that there's going to be a
first chick that's a president,
I think.
I think it was good to have a first
black president as much as A.
People didn't think that that was a,
you know,
like important.
It was important.
Socially it's important.
It's important.
Like having a chick president would be
interesting.
It'd be interesting.
I'd like to see where it goes.
The problem with her is she represents
like the oldest form of government.
She's like,
do you remember that movie?
Um,
what was the fucking movie where there
were the elder vampires?
You know what I'm talking about?
Like there was the Oh,
blade,
the movie blade,
right where they were the ones that were
turned into vampires.
And then there was the old ones who are
born vampires.
There were natural born vampires.
Right.
And they didn't like blade because he
was half human and he was,
you know,
he was made
day Walker.
He said,
well,
he was a day walker because he was half
human.
He could.
He could hang around a daytime.
I still maintain that first fucking
movie,
that first blade movies.
One of my all time favorite comic book
movies.
Have you ever watched it lately?
No.
I'm not going to do it.
Either breaks and everything's breaking.
No,
I'm not going.
I'm not gonna Watch us and one of my all
time favorite comic book movies.
I fucking loved that movie,
but that was the thing.
So Hillary Clinton's like,
she's one of those born vampires.
She murders murders a lot of people is
what you're saying?
I'm not saying she merged a lot of
people.
I'm saying people that get into conflict
with her wind up dead as fuck,
right.
Whatever.
Are we what?
Jamie?
What number are we on now?
It's 49,
right?
I think up to somewhere,
as the Internet says it's up to 49,
but now
coincidence or is this evidence like
when we look at an evidence or or is
this just will look at what these people
are doing and the last guy seemed to be
like a robbery attempt or something like
that because it was 4:00
in the morning.
He got shot walking down the street and
Washington like know Washington's a
notoriously dangerous place.
Me and barrier got elected after he got
arrested,
went to jail for crack.
He then he got elected again.
That's true.
Right?
And it's a beehive for crazy people
because anyone that likes government.
Look,
the guy that climbed trump tower,
he's a crazy person.
Who,
if you saw his interview he talking
about yesterday,
they don't know.
You didn't hear about this.
Oh my God.
This was like the biggest thing for like
three hours.
This guy was suction cups,
climbing the trump tower.
Like,
like police busting windows out of
trump's windows,
like trying to grab and get.
Couldn't get him.
He kept on climbing.
He released the guy released a video
like 12 hours before Sam,
and if you listen to the video,
it sounds like
a youtube commentor like it.
It's just like,
like I want to give a mess appearance.
I just don't know how many people will
walk this.
I'd rather not be recognizable.
I'm an independent researcher.
We're good.
I've had my fill,
but it was pretty intense because he got
up pretty high and could for awhile.
I didn't think the police were going to
be able to do anything but watching them
work in their,
their tactics to catch a guy that has
suction cups,
cups.
Very interesting.
This is when they pull him in and he,
he means stone.
It's like right here at me and he's.
But he's still connected to the rope.
There's probably beating the fuck out of
here it is.
Dick's getting together,
trying to undo them.
They're just going to cut it.
No,
they ended up pulling it off somehow.
But they destroyed that,
that,
that building.
They broke a lot of windows.
Cut a lot of like crates or uh,
air conditioning.
What a crazy fucker.
Yeah.
It not what happens to a guy like that.
How long you go to jail for.
Wow.
I don't know that.
So I think that's a.
whilst the charges today,
I was going to look at that second.
I think mental,
he's gonna be in a mental hospital more
so than a a,
a jail it seems like,
but these kind of people or the people
that hang out in like Washington DC and
stuff.
That's why DC or Washington so a so
dangerous,
you know,
it's,
it's because they're attracted to this
crazy thing that's already happening.
A hive of government and everybody knows
it's got to a centralized location
because the hive,
Washington DC's the hive of our
government and the penthouse is a or the
Pentagon.
Penthouse.
The Pentagon is not that far from there.
Right.
How far is that?
It's in Virginia,
right?
How far by air is the Pentagon or the
White House?
Yeah,
they're fairly close to each other,
right?
Probably be like a 12 hour drive.
Something like that I guess isn't.
I don't know that whole area though.
I would imagine.
And there's also that giant community of
lobbyists that lives in Virginia just
outside of Washington dc that,
uh,
Brian Cowen was telling me some of the
richest people per capita in the
country,
right?
Pc Cemetery.
It's just across the river from.
And I'm pretty sure it was pretty close.
Oh Wow.
I was way off.
I had no idea it was that close to all
of our driver.
It's a 12 minute walk from the Pentagon.
I mean,
it's just literally really across the
river.
Holy Shit.
I thought it was more like a half hour
away in bad traffic.
But yeah,
maybe that's what it is.
I thought it was like a over the river
and through the woods to grandmother's
house.
We go.
It's close as fuck.
So the point being that that's a,
that's a hub.
So that one last guy that got shot,
man,
anybody who get shot in Washington DC
walking around the street at 4:00
in the morning and get shot,
it can happen.
You can zig zagged.
You could rock it to the wrong dude at
the wrong time.
And it can happen.
It's just part of living in a high crime
area,
so who knows if that one was,
but there's a gang of them that are
connected to the Clintons that just
wound them getting whacked.
Did you see all the crime that's been
going on in the Olympics?
Like I sent Jamie this video of in
Brazil and it's just a collection of
like the first or second day of the.
They have like these people just
watching the streets for crime and it's
just tons of these petty theft like
people getting,
trying to just steal people's stuff and
this video,
I mean this came out I think the first
or second day,
but this video is nonstop.
It's just happening like people just
coming up and trying to steal people's
cell phones and some guys are really
smart with it.
They get on these bikes and you now when
you're looking at your cell phone,
you're just kind of holding it barely
and people are just coming up and taking
their phones on bikes and then taking
off and it's.
It's crazy.
This guy is the biggest pussy in the
road by the way.
Right here.
Look how small that little kid is and he
knows like guys following him,
he's getting close to his girl and he's
just not doing anything and then this
kid ends up stealing something from the
guy in front of them.
Wow.
Right here.
Blank.
Hey Man.
That's just taking part of the process.
Yeah.
Some people
super disenfranchise and poor and that
was something that Byron bowers who
talked about in the podcast,
the difference between people that are
just trying to survive,
they're just trying to survive.
Man.
That is a totally different world that
grow and fight at all.
She's just like,
just give it up.
Okay.
Um,
so how many people have supposedly been
whacked?
What does the Internet believe?
I think it was 49.
Oh,
I got to find the.
But is there anybody that makes a
compelling case?
It says 96.
Right?
I don't know if that's.
I mean it depends on which website you
want to look up and find who was
conspiracy.
Do you want to dig down?
It's on snoopy's or snopes?
No.
Here's what one of the weirdest things
about government is that it affects all
of us right in this room,
but we couldn't be further away from the
type of person that would want to run
the government.
Like I don't want to run shit.
You don't want to run shit.
You know,
like the type of people that do want to
do that.
They are so not like most people.
Most people do not want to run
everybody.
When you get people that are in that
like higher echelon of government and
they have the ability literally to
manipulate which way the country thinks
that without really persuasive,
articulate speech,
they really have the opportunity to
change the way the country feels about
itself.
You know,
like,
like Kennedy,
like his summer Kennedy's speeches.
You would,
you would listen to them and you would
want to be a better person.
You hear that guy talk and he,
he said such poetic shit.
It was so brilliant and the way he was
able to communicate and a
lot of blase,
like a lot of people thought Obama was
going to be like that too because it
seemed like he kind of was when he was
running for office and we seemed like
when this guy gets in,
man,
he's going to make some of those Kennedy
type speeches and he made some really
good speeches for sure,
but it always felt like he was.
Everything was down the middle,
like everything was like a 90 Sitcom,
you know?
It's like there was not much chances
being taken.
It was like you wanted Seinfeld and you
got mad about you.
You know what I mean?
You know what I'm saying?
Not that there's anything wrong with mad
about you.
So fine program went along on a long
time.
A lot of people enjoyed it,
you know,
but it wasn't curb your enthusiasm.
You know,
there's,
when,
when a guy comes out like Obama and his
speeches at the Democratic convention
before he was elected,
he was like,
Holy Shit.
Like this is going to be the guy who's
going to be this super articulate,
powerful,
powerful guy who writes all the wrongs,
so one of two options,
either one,
he was never really liked that and it
was just tricking us and is brilliant.
Like a portrayal of this rebel of this
person who's gonna come in and give you
hope and change or two,
you get in there and the sobering effect
of what you're presented with every day
makes you realize like,
oh my God,
they're just running around putting out
fires all the time.
There's a fucking like what you're
seeing from those kids in that video in
the Olympics where these people are
getting a purse snatched and shit.
Tourists are getting personality pick
pocketed.
That is just what happens when things
are all fucked up and unbalanced.
That's what happens.
It's just what happened.
That's just a whole mess.
Like do you think this is the end of the
Olympics?
Just based on like how much trouble this
Olympics has been,
you know,
looking at all the hotel rooms where the
sinks are falling through the counters
and how the water.
I don't know if you saw the water today
is green because they have an allergy
problem or something like that and if
you look at all the past Olympics and
how all the structures,
there's a website where it shows like
all the Olympics and how it just,
they have all these concrete things that
are just now overrun by a trees and
weeds and stuff and how much it costs to
make all this and now it's just ruined
land.
You know,
you can't.
Once you put concrete on land it's
pretty much ruined you.
It's really hard for it to ever be
farmed on again or things to grow when
there's concrete on there.
Yeah,
I guess it makes sense that you'd have
to look at this.
I mean this is just things apart.
This is old and as 1984 Olympics,
just try.
It looks trashy.
Oh,
they were using for a bike course.
So that's kind of done.
It looks fun.
Where's that?
Sarah Yandell.
Bosnia.
Heres A.
Hers have a golden.
Yeah.
How do you say that?
Hers is hers.
It governing his or Grovedale is a
scrolled up.
So we see that,
so we'll look at that man,
that looks fun as fuck.
These dudes are on the Bob sled run,
but it's all graffiti'd up and they're
riding bikes on it.
That looks fucking bad ass man.
If you lived there dude.
Yeah.
That would be the coolest shit ever.
If you were a kid and you were growing
up in that neighborhood,
but that's probably like a.
was probably got a lot of bullets in
that neighborhood too.
It looks like.
Yeah,
that's what they're writing away from
rape.
Like all this land,
this land is just ruined.
You know,
all skills and had dope though.
It's kind of dope right now,
but in 20 years that's going to look
even shittier.
Look at that.
A mosquito.
That's where Zika was born probably,
right?
We're looking at it right now and we're.
As we're scrolling through these
pictures for people were just listening
to the audio.
These things were available where Jamie
daily May I just typed in the old
Olympic venues.
This story will pop up if you google it.
Olympic venue.
This one right here is not even eight
years old from China.
God Damn,
this is crazy.
Look man,
like look at these buildings.
They're just completely deteriorating
and falling apart here.
What was this?
A graveyard?
There's a graveyard and the site of the
1984 Olympics.
So they had the side of the Olympics in
Sarajevo and then he turned to a
graveyard.
Hm,
okay.
Oh,
that looks fun.
To skateboard.
Yeah.
They have this crazy skin ramps ski
jumps from 84 Olympics.
Wow.
This is a really fascinating man that
we.
We do this,
you know,
but I'll tell you man,
they got me.
I was watching it the other day where
you.
Yup.
They got me.
Those fuckers now have A.
I heard a lot of criticism of it being a
fluff piece this year.
A lot of people saying like,
Hey,
I don't want to look at all these
stories that we're watching.
America's got talent.
I want us just to see sports in the
Olympics.
Yeah,
there's something to that for sure.
You know,
they're trying to create stars and make
a lot of money and make a lot of Michael
Phelps type people out of it.
The more Michael Show.
Yeah.
The more Michael Phelps people come
along to,
the more that's going to happen,
the more you get these super successful
guys that can.
They can,
you know how many limpic gold medals
that guy won like 28 or something crazy
white too.
I think you'd have to saying here's a
crazy picture of him in the pool from
this past Olympics and he swimming and
the guy he's beating is looking at him
and there was a meme that said,
this is the perfect example of losers.
Focus on winners.
Winners.
Winners focus on winning because he's
like just fucking laser beam straight on
the target and the.
Yeah.
The guy's looking at him like,
fuck yeah,
I remember when that picture is so
classic.
That is a man saying,
fuck.
I mean when I was back in the day,
believe it or not,
I was on track.
I remember winning the best tips was
never looked back because every time he
looked back,
that takes like a second off your time.
And,
and that's the same thing.
If that's what he's doing it,
you know,
he might not,
he might just be breathing and you might
be breathing,
but it certainly looks like he's looking
right at Michael Phelps.
So it's good for the narrative.
It's A.
It's interesting that Michael Phelps won
all those gold medals in swimming and
then he became this huge swimming star
because think about how many swimming
stars I've been.
How many other is Greg Louganis who was
more of a diving star that a swimming
star?
Name me another famous swimmer.
Summer Sanders.
I don't know who the fuck that is.
She's not famous like Michael Phelps
that even the neighborhood.
I've never been heard of her.
No,
no fence Ma'am does nickelodeon shows?
Oh,
she did?
Okay.
That's Kinda cool.
But Michael Phelps is like,
here's the,
here's how I feel about sports.
If I know your name,
God damn.
He wants to be famous because I barely
pay attention.
So that's how I looked like I knew about
Michael Phelps years and years and years
and years ago.
So if I know about him,
he's got to be famous as fuck.
It's crazy that like every now and then
a sport,
we'll give you a one super famous person
like one Lance Armstrong,
Tony Hawk,
and then once we got one of those,
that's it.
You Got Michael Phelps.
There was all these other guys that were
on a relay with him.
They didn't even mention that fucking
Niggas over here.
Nobody cares about that guy.
They barely paid attention.
They just focused all on Phillips Golf.
Name three names and golf.
Oh,
this guy.
That's right.
Mark Spitz.
I don't remember that guy.
He was a [inaudible] 76 Olympics I
think.
Is that right?
It has to be.
He looks like Burt Reynolds from
deliverance was 72 72.
Yeah,
man.
That's right.
I forgot about that guy.
Okay.
So he was the first of the um,
the superstar Michael Phelps type
swimmer dudes I think before,
I want to say before Phelps came along
and I really don't know,
but I think that Spitz was the guy who
won the most gold medals up until that
moment.
And then Phelps just fucking blew him
out of the water.
Where is he now?
Um,
if I had to guess by the way it looks
and an burt reynolds movie from the
Nineteen Seventies.
Yeah,
look at him.
I hope that guy still rocks that.
Look.
I wonder if being in water more than a
more average,
the average person is better or worse
for your,
your skin.
For every.
Probably worse because chlorine is not
good for you.
Sure.
It's not good for you.
Chlorine kills everything that's in the
water,
but it also fucks with the floor of your
own skin.
Like it's not the best stuff in the
world for your skin.
I mean it's sterile water.
What about saltwater?
That's probably better for you.
Yeah.
Let's say salt.
Water is better for you.
Yeah.
So water is interesting man,
because I can't get it in my eyes.
I know some people can get it in their
eyes.
They don't have a problem with it.
I get in my eyes and fucking stings.
I don't know why.
Like when I go to,
uh,
the,
the beach,
if I get water in my eyes,
it fucking stinks.
Is that add to your sodium levels?
Mark Spitz wasn't even using a swim cap.
When you're saying in your eyes were
stinging.
He doesn't have goggles on either.
He's got.
Yeah,
but I'm talking about a pool.
He swam in a pool and the ocean is where
my eyes sting.
But uh,
yeah.
Mark Spitz was old school is.
Fuck you probably swam in a flannel
shirt.
Those look at his body.
Short shorts have probably made from
like red dye number nine.
They didn't do any strength and
conditioning back there stops throwing
me.
Just men in their underwear.
Jamie stop it.
The iconic speedo endures.
So this a go to full body on this
gentlemen.
Look at his fucking body man.
It's like,
you mean,
I guess he kind of looks like an athlete
or he looks like a,
your girlfriend's brother that's staying
with her over the.
You know,
you get up in the morning,
you meet him for the first time.
Well how are you doing man?
Nice to meet you.
Oh Hey man.
Y'All got soap.
Like that's what he looks like.
He's like some,
some weird fucking dude might've worked
out a couple of times in his underwear.
Like,
why are you just standing your in your
underwear like that dude with gold
chains around your neck?
This is a fucking strange picture.
It doesn't really look to swimmer body
either.
Like the difference between that body
and Michael Phelps body or any swimmer
nowadays.
It's like pretty different.
Like his legs actually seemed kind of
Chubby.
They're like,
uh.
I don't know.
They don't really seem muscular.
They kind of seem sexy,
but what I'm just strengthened.
But does Michael Phelps do strength and
conditioning workouts?
I know he does that crazy cupping shit.
You're paying attention to that?
Yeah.
Everybody's copying these days.
He's wacky.
Kids saw that and that.
That falls into the chiropractor.
Bullshit stuff,
right?
Like the like there's real no science
behind it at all.
I've just anecdotal evidence.
There's no,
I don't think there's been scientific
studies done on unfortunately.
Oh,
here's a breakdown of his training.
Routine warmup with Jack Knife crunches,
three sets of 20 pushups,
three tests of 25 to 35 and bodyweight
squats,
three sets of 25 begin the pool with 40
50 meter drills.
So it's mostly swimming stuff,
which seems like in some body weight
exercises,
crunches and squats,
but the majority of his stuff is about
lapse.
High intensity swim distances of 200
meters,
150 meters,
100 meters,
50 meters with 30 seconds of rest in
between each interval.
He's a fucking animal.
Just think about doing that sprints with
high intensity.
What is a high intensity to the greatest
swimmer of the world's ever known?
Can you even imagine operating those
Rpms that he considered high intensity
when that fucking guy gets going in a
pool,
dude,
get video of him getting super-intense,
getting warmed up for his race the other
day.
No,
I didn't say it.
It's kind of funny.
The Dude's dancing around in front of
them.
It's fast.
Yeah.
He's a beast.
You've got to be.
You have to have like an insanely
powerful mind to be able to do something
that everybody can do like swim and do
it faster than anybody ever.
You got to be a fucking real super
focused psycho mean psycho in a bad way.
Oh,
he looks like a psycho.
I mean,
that death stare he did fucking crazy.
So this is him.
Michael Phelps.
What does it say?
Stairs.
A death stare of intimidation is going
viral.
Oh,
this is like some compilation with a
talking head person.
What,
what is the youtube thing where they,
they edit every five seconds.
You say something,
say something.
Edit.
And it's like constantly.
There's no,
there's no,
there's no normal talking.
It's like you're on speed.
Adhd for today's millennials.
Started with natural born killers.
So one guy is like dancing,
like he's not even dancing.
He's like shadow boxing.
Is that going to have fighter team?
South America?
Why is he staring at Michael Phelps?
And he's just showing off for him.
Like he's like shaking in front of them
and laughing.
Michael Phelps does not give a fuck.
He's probably happy that guy's doing
that.
You know,
it's a little test,
a little test for him to uh,
just continuous stare of death.
Whoa.
That's pretty funny man.
He's probably listening to some killer
creed music or something.
And His earphones because Michael Phelps
listened to my dad.
He doesn't give a fuck.
That is weird.
But the,
I think you just got to be that guy if
you want to be that good,
who else is as good as him?
Nobody ever.
Right.
Who else was that intense?
Nobody.
He takes it on to the next level.
God Damn crazy people out there winning
gold medals.
Pretty fucking impressive.
Smokes.
A lot of wheat.
I hear.
Yeah.
Sabika weed.
Did you hear about the dea this morning?
That really pissed me off.
They decided not to reclassify
marijuana.
So they're keeping it in the same
category as heroin and stuff.
They decided that it has no medical
benefits.
Why can't we just take him to one of
these kids that have seizures and just
go here,
watch,
see seizure now.
See no seizure.
Okay.
Shut the fuck up.
You know,
common sense knows common sense here,
right?
Yeah.
I mean that's,
that's definitely evidence.
But I mean there's many,
many cases of that that is evidence that
there's tests being done on these
children in the real world and it's
working.
I mean,
whether or not it's scientific,
you know,
double blind,
placebo controlled evidence.
No,
but there's plenty of evidence about the
medicinal benefits of cannabis.
There's plenty of it.
There's plenty.
There's.
There's all sorts of data that seems to
indicate that it has some sort of a role
in reducing tumors.
It can.
It definitely helps people with anxiety.
There's A.
There's a lot of factors that it does
that like you know,
when Neal Brennan was on,
he was talking about antidepressants and
he was like,
they don't exactly know how they work
and that's a really good point,
but they sell fucking ton of different
kinds of antidepressants.
They know how cannabis works.
They know that there's cannabinoid
receptors in the human mind,
meaning the human brain is designed or
grew up or developed alongside
cannabis.
It knows what to do with it,
so when you take marijuana,
your body knows what it is.
Your body even produces some sort of
cannabinoid response.
When you run.
That's part of what you're getting in
the runner's high.
They say it's similar.
Is that correct?
I think that's correct.
How is this a true statement that they
add in there that they don't know the
drugs?
Chemistry is not known or reproducible,
that says no current obsession,
accepted medical use because the drugs
chemistry is not reproducible,
not known,
and reproducible means what?
What does that mean?
Meaning drugs.
Chemistry is not known in reproducible.
Meaning they can't create it in a lab.
Yeah.
Or they can't make two of the same.
Maybe Maggie.
You can't keep the same.
You can't clone the same person over and
over again.
Every time he hits a different person,
maybe because when you get it as
marijuana,
there's hundreds of different types of
cannabinoids apparently,
and you're not just getting thc.
You're getting all kinds of other groovy
shit in there too,
but yeah,
I think there's a ton of different types
of cannabinoids.
Let's go down a little fucking
information whole young Jamie.
How many things?
I'm going to guess.
There's 100 different types of
cannabinoids.
What do you think?
I would guess over a thousand.
Boom.
Jesus Christ.
I also think it's 12 hours to the
Pentagon.
80 five.
Cannabis contains at least 85 types of
cannabinoids.
Many which have documented medical
value.
That was 2014.
They probably found new ones.
Bitch.
Okay,
now there's only over 480 natural
components found in the cannabis sativa
plant.
Okay,
there you go.
So that's different.
So it's 480 natural components.
So 113 different canabinoids says one in
wicken in wikipedia.
So you know,
it's real.
Um,
scroll down.
One more.
The one that says how many different
cannabinoids?
Sixty four.
Yeah.
So at the answers vary depending on
studying year.
This is the most recent one,
right?
This is 2000.
One hundred 11.
I think that's this 1964.
But if you scroll up it's the post is
from 2015.
Yeah.
So I don't think this is old information
right?
There wouldn't be used in 2011 data
would they just says that the thc was
first discovered in 1964.
You know,
that's really crazy that,
you know,
when they're talking about like data
that we're talking about like well they
wouldn't be using data from like 20
years ago,
like fucking ads.
He didn't know shit back then when we
really do kind of think about it that
way sometimes.
Like somebody sent me something the
other day that was from three years ago
and I immediately was like,
fucking three years old,
but it was a really interesting story,
but unless it was happening that week,
you know,
so what that.
What is that?
That's weird.
That sounds like an assumption.
Everyone.
Other people have done more research up
until now and I've looked at that maybe
I would assume that a lot of times I
think if I saw something that said it
was last month,
I would think at least five people I've
seen it since then.
And snopes stood out and wrote another
article.
Yeah,
but it's not even that.
It's an actual news event.
Not at non.
It's not debatable.
Just an actual news event from two years
ago is bullshit.
I don't give a fuck about it.
It's weird like you look down,
like whenever there's an article that
someone will tweet or I find online or
reading it on dig or something like
that.
If I find an old article or if I'm
researching the subject,
if I just start googling it and find
something from 2013,
I all almost instantly go.
It's like three years old,
man sold back then.
They didn't know anything back then.
It's also like two,
three,
eight phone generations old too.
I think that's what you think.
Yeah.
I know you see someone like from 2003
with a flip phone,
you want to go,
you fucking moron.
I'm looking very matrix
that they just had like those little
slide out phones.
No concept of what an iphone was even
going to be.
Then I don't think,
and they weren't even discussing what
that would have been like to have social
media or any.
They're just texting each other I think.
And making phone calls.
Yeah.
No,
that's one of the interesting things
about science fiction,
is it science fiction is a really poor
indicator of what the future holds in
most situations.
You know,
like no one who did star wars or star
Trek,
they didn't think there would be able to
communicate with each other in real time
all around the world through video and
send emails and get all the information,
but anything you wanted to get at any
given time wirelessly through the air
and a little thing that's so small,
it's slides in your front pocket.
Nobody ever thought that was coming.
Now Dee,
the day they just said how they're doing
like the five g right now and how back
in the day,
you know we started off with three g or
whatever way tbg and stuff like that and
now I think there's only a few countries
where 75 percent of the country is still
using two,
two g or three G and how they've run out
of frequencies to build the five g.
But or so now they're going to have to
start just kicking people off the two G
and three g and stuff like that.
But back then we had three gene.
We were like,
oh,
this is great.
We can send text messages and we could
send pictures.
Now.
They didn't,
weren't even thinking about Netflix,
hd streaming,
you know,
I was just thinking,
what if he gets kicked off because this
phone can't keep up with the new shit.
That's definitely happening.
I was thinking maybe they should make a
new phone called the throwback for
people like Ari and then this phone just
only has numbers on it.
Can't even text.
Call me bitch a windows phone doesn't
even get a text message.
Just gets calls like an old Motorola
Tristar.
I was trying to talk.
Talk
to my dad about this today.
How important is that phone number still
to like a person is.
It's like because there's so many
different ways to communicate and you
can communicate through voice and video
that facebook
through facetime,
audio and Wifi.
Do you really still need that 10 digit
phone number?
Change my phone number almost every year
now.
And it's nowadays it doesn't matter.
It's a better way to weed out people
that shouldn't have your phone number.
Like I used to think that,
oh,
I had this number since I was 14,
you know,
and now I don't give a fuck anymore.
I know I keep my phone on the sleep mode
or whatever the,
the moon that doesn't let any phone
calls go through and it doesn't
interrupt you with alerts or anything
and,
but if somebody calls you like two times
in a row or three times in a row it goes
through,
but it,
it,
like I accidentally leave it on all the
time and I'm like,
you know,
this is so peaceful.
Not hearing my fucking phone beeping and
ringing.
And so I think that's important because
I think we forget that we didn't have
that growing up most of our lives and
now it's almost like an alarm clock
going off every two minutes.
You know?
It's not,
it doesn't give you a chance to live
like a normal life.
If you're constantly updating yourself
with twitter or with
text messages and you're constantly
looking at it.
That's what your focus is on.
And it's almost like you're not even
living your life.
You're living your life through this
screen.
Like you're going into another world
like this artificially created world and
that's how you're existing in a world
where no one's talking.
If they are talking to,
talking to you,
like you click on a video,
who you,
most of the time what's going on as
you're reading stuff,
you're reading stuff or someone sending
something,
lol.
They're sending you a funny meme.
You're like,
ah,
you know,
there's,
there's those things and that's like how
people are living.
Like people are like seeking out funny
instagram posts,
you know,
and like I,
I have friends that have,
they subscribed to like 10 different
funny instagram meme posts and just
every 15 seconds they'll look at it,
their phone going,
ah,
you know,
and you can do that.
Like you can be fucking perpetually
entertained all day if you choose to do
that.
If you follow the right instagram memes
and you have the right people on twitter
that send you the interesting shit
because there's always something new.
There's always some new fucking crazy
thing.
You're going to be constant,
constantly entertained.
Going back to the marijuana thing with
the dea that they had that happen,
they had to read or do that because the
governor got so many signed petitions or
assigned names that it forced them to
have to reclassify the marijuana.
I don't know what governor,
but whoever it was,
you know,
if they,
uh,
they acquiesce to the demands of the
Internet,
right.
We definitely didn't do it enough then.
So.
So if more ramped up and they say that
they couldn't clot,
reclassify that to keep it the same
because they couldn't find any health
benefits from it.
Right.
So what happens if the same governor
gets all the signatures to reclassify
cigarettes or alcohol?
What would the da have to say then for
the health benefits of those two?
Would they have to reclassify it as
illegal?
It's a very good point.
Let's try it.
See what happens.
I'd love to see what happens.
It's a very
good point.
It's a very good point.
And here's another really good point.
The classifying it in schedule one,
because that's where it's been and
because they're they claim there's no
known medical use or it can't be
reproducible.
Whatever the fuck that means you can
grow it dummy.
You can get clones and grow it.
Of course it's reproducible.
It's just reproducible as a plant.
So what they're saying is it trying to
classify it as a drug,
what they're almost admitting themselves
if,
if what we're thinking is true.
If what they're saying is that you
can't,
it's not reproducible because it's not a
chemical that you can break down into a
pill if that's what they're saying.
Like you can't standardize it because
it's too wild and it's free.
It's growing.
That's almost a perfect example of the
fact that you're.
You're not.
You shouldn't be in a position where
you're controlling a plant.
You shouldn't have be in a position
where you're regulating nature,
but that's so you're almost admitting it
yourself.
It's not reproducible.
Okay?
If that's what you're saying,
then you're saying it's not a drug.
Okay,
so,
but as a psychoactive effect,
okay,
now you have to prove that psychoactive
effect is dangerous.
There's nothing that's the real problem.
The real problem is classified in the
category of the most dangerous,
harmful drugs.
There is no evidence that that's should
that.
That should be correct.
There's no evidence,
so that's where the dea is failing.
They're failing way more in that than
they are in even not admitting that
there's medical evidence because if you
wanted to follow it to the strictest
sense of the word,
what studies have been done that have
absolutely been proven in a new modern
form of like the most current science,
what studies have been done that show
the medical benefits of cannabis?
I'm not that many studies being done,
but it's because it's classified as
schedule one.
It's a total catch 22.
It's hard to get studies done because
it's a schedule one and so you can't
prove it shouldn't be a schedule one
because there's not very many studies,
but there's a ton of studies that have
been done by universities.
There's a ton of studies that have shown
positive benefits.
If you want to go back into history,
even back into the Nixon administration,
they were running studies that they
buried the results because the results
showed no harm.
They showed nothing.
They can't,
so when you follow just straight
science,
there's no.
There's no evidence whatsoever.
It should be illegal.
That's the most important thing.
It's not evidence of whether it should
be legal.
That's like,
you know the whole thing about you're
innocent until proven guilty.
It should be the same way about
marijuana.
It should be that you can't just make it
illegal and say it has to remain illegal
because we don't know what it can do
because you do know can do you do.
You definitely know.
Why do you think that millions of people
like it?
Are they all crazy?
What's going on?
All these millions and millions of
adults that live in America,
are they fucking crazy?
So what are you saying?
You're saying you're smarter than them.
Why don't you talk about it with
somebody that knows what the fuck
they're talking about and you'll get
buried.
Talk about it with a person who's like
talking about it with like todd
mccormick committed Tom Mccormick having
a debate with one of these dea guys
about whether or not marijuana is
beneficial.
He survived cancer because of it.
Now a lot of people have.
We have friends that have kids that have
autism.
They give their fucking kids this
medical cannabis and all of a sudden
they can talk.
They relax,
they stop having seizures.
It's a massive benefit to a lot of
people.
It relaxes people,
makes people feel good,
and we have a government agency in 2016
that ignores all of that and wants to
keep it in the category of some of the
most harmful and dangerous drugs.
These people that live in an episode of
Hawaii,
five o delivered in the past,
they're like 19 fifties people and what
they think they can do is keep this,
this bureaucracy and this paperwork and
these classifications in in movement and
they can head off freedom because what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to stop freedom and one of the reasons
why they trap trying to stop freedom is
because they benefit from it.
They benefit from stopping it.
They have more agents.
If those eight,
if all of a sudden most drugs are legal,
what do those fucking thousands of Dea
agents going to do?
They have.
They're protecting their own industry.
This is a natural thing that any
organism does when it's threatened and
if you start making drugs legal and you
start opening up that conversation like,
who the fuck is any one adult to tell
any other adult,
what's good or bad for you?
When a lot of shit we do,
whether it's the food,
we eat,
the alcohol,
we drank the cigarettes,
we smoke the fucking sugar in our diet.
All these things are bad for us.
We all know that,
but we were afraid it was the government
going to come in with a fucking machine
guns to stop you from eating a chocolate
cake and smoking a cigarette.
Fuck that.
Right?
I think we all agree on that.
If you.
If they can't do that,
they shouldn't be able to stop you from
smoking weed.
This is archaic.
This is like this is some ancient
fucking vampire shit and they're
clinging to civilization.
They are totally irrelevant,
totally irrelevant.
Your decision should be made 100 percent
on the facts that are available today.
You can go.
You could research all the facts about
matter.
Marijuana.
You find a few that make correlations
between some sort of mental illnesses,
but those core,
most of the time,
at least according to experts that I've
listened to talk about it,
the correlations of schizophrenia to
marijuana use are directly in
proportionate with the court.
The numbers of schizophrenia for any
given population that there's always
going to be around one percent of the
population that suffers from some type
of schizophrenia or severe mental
distraction.
Illness.
You know,
a bunch of different categories.
These little various mental diseases,
but it's always that number,
so if they smoked pot,
it's just a thousand people that smoked
pot have schizophrenia.
Okay.
If there was the same amount of people
and they didn't smoke pot,
it might be the same amount of
schizophrenia,
x,
they might not even be connected,
but when you're talking about 300
million people and you say 30,000
people got schizophrenia for marijuana,
are you fucking sure?
Are you a really fucking sure.
Or is it just 30,000
people have schizophrenia and they also
smoke marijuana.
This is the car.
This is a real problem with the way they
present the data because it's just like
you coming up to me or to Jamie and you
saying you've got new rules.
You as a 42 year old grown ass man.
You have new rules and we did.
You don't want us drinking alcohol
anymore.
You're gonna.
You're gonna come in and you've hired
guards to keep us from smoking alcohol
or drinking alcohol.
It's the same thing.
If it's a 50,000
people with some big building with three
letters in the front event or whether
it's one crazy fuck,
who wants to stop his neighbor from
smoking pot?
It's the same thing.
You're trying to stop someone from doing
something that's not bad like you can't
do that.
You don't have any evidence that it's
bad.
There should be a fuck load of evidence
that if it's bad and it should be as
much or worse than all the shit that you
know is bad that you sell open and make
money from taxes,
alcohol,
which we both love.
I love,
but here's a great example.
I talk a lot.
They just recently released a study that
I think this week showing the like they
proved scientifically that wheat is
better for sex and they not only did it
for pleasures,
but they also explained how when you
have alcohol,
you,
you cheat more,
you do bad things.
You Hook up with people who shouldn't
do.
You don't use condoms.
Like do a lot of shit that a lot of
people change.
Like I'm on team boobs,
let's do this danger style,
but it's shit that is life changing and
getting a girl pregnant that you hook
met at a bar that looked hot last night.
You wake up and it's a dog,
you know,
like all the dog.
You're talking about a woman,
a woman human.
How dare you know is that slut shaming
about Shit's actually.
There was an article on a website that I
go to all the time and I don't want to
make fun of the man who wrote it because
I love him,
but it was about.
It was about fat shaming in martial arts
is Julianna Pena fat shames Ronda Rousey
and Julianna Pena,
who's a one of the toughest 135 pound
fighters in the women's Bantamweight
Division in the UFC.
She's bad ass.
She talking some shit.
She's trying to get people to pay
attention to her.
I mean this will.
Conor mcgregor did so a lot of these
fucking people do.
It's a smart business move.
Okay,
so that we all should be aware of.
Right?
I mean,
it's not just a person saying this is
someone.
It's a smart business move,
so she says this quote about Ronda
Rousey and she says something about
Ronda Rousey having fat arms,
and so the title of this whole piece,
she wants to beat her ass.
Okay.
This which she wants to do to Ronda
Rousey,
she wants to hold her down and she wants
a mounir.
She wants to elbow her face bloody.
She wants to punch her eyes so that
they're swollen and shut down.
She wants to get behind her and choke
her and say nasty shit to where she puts
her unconscious.
That's what she wants to do.
That's what you would like to do,
right?
That's what almost all of these fighters
would like to do.
When they're locked in mortal combat,
they want to beat the other person's ass
and they want to choke them out.
Right.
The nasty stuff I made,
I put that in myself.
I'm in,
you know,
point being.
I've seen people say some nasty shit to
people whether choking them out by the
way,
but point being that seems to be way
worse than Sanchez fat arms.
Right?
What's this going to look like?
What's her face?
Look beautiful.
We're going opinions.
Beautiful.
She's beautiful,
she's beautiful,
but.
So it's Ronda Rousey,
but she said,
you know that she said something about
Ronda Rousey having fat arms.
I forget what the quote was about.
Something about she's over her and you
know the fucking the tie.
One of the things that it said,
yeah,
no one cares about Ronda rousey and her
fat arms anymore.
It's listen,
that's a funny thing to say and you see
Julia and opinions.
He appreciated.
Yeah,
except for that knows.
She just got beat up.
That was a fight.
That's all swollen up,
right?
They're not even beat up.
She's never been beat up and she's a bad
ass.
She's tough and she's trying to make
some try and make some waves.
But the article that I read was talking
about the fat shaming that women should
never fat.
Shame each other.
Women fighters shouldn't fetch.
And I'm like,
listen,
it's called talking shit.
It's called talking shit.
You can't stop them from talking shit by
putting it to this new category.
Fat Shaming.
What?
That is the most mild form of mockery
ever.
A beautiful woman who has big arms,
she'll fucking throw you on your head
with those big arms.
There's a reason for those fucking
things,
man.
They work.
I did date a girl with big arms.
It was weird because I say it's so
beautiful.
Had a nice body,
but for some reason her arms are about
double time.
And so if she were the wrong shirts,
it was very uncomfortable to continue to
look at,
you know,
how you have those,
like a sexual,
actual paids when you're like a in your
early 19,
20 years,
you know,
like 20,
21 you have.
Like sometimes you only meet someone
you've never seen him again.
And this is a,
this is even more interesting because
it's,
you know,
there was no cell phones back then,
so you couldn't really get in touch with
people that well,
you got to call them at home if the
phone didn't pick up,
they didn't have an answer.
Machine couldn't even leave a message.
It was weird back then.
Right?
But uh,
I hooked up with this chick that I
always thought I've thought about for
years after,
like whatever happened to that girl,
she was a bank,
oh fuck.
And she was in the weightlifting,
like,
seriously in a weightlifting and she had
a full on six pack.
Wow.
I've got a full six pack.
She was like frank and she had these big
ass fucking squatter legs and she was a
freak.
And I always remember like,
God damn,
like whatever happened,
that crazy girl,
she was fun.
You didn't look her up,
you didn't find her and if she's too big
for me,
man made me nervous.
She made me nervous.
I'm not kidding.
I mean she was real nice and she lived
like really far away to a thing.
She was like an hour and a half away
from me.
An hour and a half drive,
just,
you know,
those don't work out when you're 20 and
you're
busy with a million other things.
But she was a tank.
Yeah.
I've been with a couple of girls that
were in mma to mma girls type girls'
bodies and it's not comfortable and
thinking like,
oh,
this girl can kill me if I didn't like
having sex with them was weird.
It was just like,
I feel like I'm fucking a guy.
We did a fica pen and the other day and
uh,
Eddie Bravo was drunk off his rocker and
we were all having fun and talking about
whether or not female UFC fighters,
like what,
what untrained male could fuck up a
female UFC fighter.
Like how big does the woman have to be?
How big is the man?
I got to be.
We got the Cyborg versus Ray Lewis.
It was one of the most ridiculous
conversations we've ever had.
And he got to the point where he was
using like social justice warrior
tactics.
He said that we all hated women and he
was insisting that a good day,
uh,
he wanted to have,
who's a bad ass fighter.
But she also fights 100,
15 pounds.
Like how big would the man have to be
for like a,
we're thinking like a 190 pounds
untrained man I'm on.
And then we've got to be like,
okay,
well what's untrained?
What if he has a year of high school
wrestling,
have a year of high school wrestling.
That's the guy who understands how to
take people down at the very least.
And if he gets on top of you in 190
pounds a year,
1:15
you might be Foxville.
Right?
And so then we got into this crazy
conversation.
Then it got to blink.
Seibold will fuck up any untrained dude.
What about Ray Lewis?
And then it got site.
So inside his twitter page,
Ray Lewis,
249 pounds.
It says Chris Cyborg,
1:39.
That is a fucking lie.
Cris Cyborg.
First of all,
I think they should make a 145 pound
weight class just for her because the
UFC right now has to 115 and 135
recognized classes and the women's
division and they had sideboard get down
to 1:40
for one fight.
She fought a Leslie Smith at 1:40,
so that's more realistic that she weighs
1:45,
but you really only weighs 1:45
after a brutal weight cut.
She's probably closer to one 65 five.
Yeah,
in real life,
but they keep making it get down to
1:40,
which I don't.
I don't fucking.
It's not like she's not going to fight
at 1:35.
She's too big,
but there's a video of her making weight
for 1:40
that she just put up.
It's horrific,
man.
She's crying.
She's like broken down.
I mean they get so fucking drained and
then they got to fight 24 hours later.
It's crazy.
The whole process is crazy.
It's dangerous and it's stupid and it's
unnecessary.
You should let these athletes like they
should figure out what I think the real
problem is.
Here's one of the problems.
Is there a specific weight classes?
Right?
There's like 1:55.
There's 1:17
is one of 85 and in each specific weight
class the guy has.
There's a champion,
right?
But the,
the,
the variety of people like what your
natural weight should be,
it's really should be what you are when
you're healthy in shape and you're
walking around and ideally that's
exactly where you should be fighting.
The problem is people are going to
fucking game the system and I think what
we have to do is we have to shame people
that try to gain the system.
People that try to dehydrate themselves
and fight smaller people.
That's like contrary to everything that
martial arts is supposed to be about.
You're supposed to be.
It's supposed to be about testing your
skills and especially in the competition
sense versus someone who the exact same
size as you,
so you're testing your skills,
you're testing your ability against
someone who is the same size as you,
but if you pretend that you're that size
but you only that size for like an hour
because you dehydrate yourself but then
you below up and you're much bigger
after it's over.
That's sort of contrary to what martial
arts is supposed to be about.
Do you think it's the frequency of the
UFC is how many there are?
How many,
you mean they're flooding the UFC?
There's one almost every two weeks now.
Do you think if they were like,
you're only allowed to fight every three
years,
but we're paying you twice as much,
do you think that would help out a
fighters?
Um,
I don't think that's the solution.
I think it's good to have a bunch of
different suggestions,
but I think what,
right now,
everyone's locked into these pathways of
fighting for titles.
This is what I think.
I think that's awesome.
Don't get me wrong.
I love when someone wins the belt.
I love it.
It's exciting.
You know,
when I get to walk up to someone and
say,
Tyron Woodley the new welterweight
champion,
the world.
Like,
how does that sound like?
That's real.
You get to participate in one of the
most special moments of an athlete's
career.
Have a fighter's entire struggle as a,
as a competitor in one of the most
difficult things a person could ever do.
So that moment is like,
that's a crazy,
critical,
huge,
massive moment for anyone.
I remember clearly saying that to me.
Should tate.
I remember clearly,
Sandra Day O'connor,
Mcgregor,
Tyron Woodley,
Robbie Lawler,
I remember it clearly.
A lot of these guys.
It's a huge,
huge moments.
Don't think the average person and even
me,
I don't think,
I mean as close as I am to the struggle,
to the fights and calling them all and
being there.
I don't think I understand it like he
understands it.
There's no way I can't.
There's no way I do.
I just don't.
So there's that.
But after that,
what do we really want to see?
We want to see the best people fight the
best people.
I don't know if the title of champion is
the best way to do that.
I mean,
we all are.
We're all obsessed with WHO's the best.
Right?
And that is a good thing I guess because
it forces people to fucking just
polished that sword to the perfect
sharpness.
But at the end of the day,
do we want to see.
We want to see the best people fight the
best people.
That's what we really want to say.
Oh,
I say dia is double slap connor in the
face at the same time.
Like,
okay,
look,
let me ask you this right now.
If somebody had to offer you a paper
review tomorrow,
if there's a paper review they were
doing tomorrow and it's Nick Diaz versus
George St Pierre.
There's no title on the line.
Who gives a fuck about a title?
I don't care at all.
I couldn't care less about a title if
it's George St Pierre Versus Nick Diaz.
I'm in.
Yeah,
right.
One hundred percent.
I think that's the same thing with tyron
woodley versus Nick Diaz or Tyron
Woodley versus George St Pierre.
Like it doesn't have to be for a title
like I want to see that.
I want to see what that is and I mean
it's amazing when a person wins the
title,
it is a gigantic achievement,
but what do you really want to see as
an.
As a person who enjoys the sport,
you want to see a guy who was beating
everybody,
right?
You want to see a guy who just keeps
beating.
Guys.
It doesn't matter if there's a belt on
the line.
If I find out that Robbie lawler's one
six fights in a row against world class
competition,
I'm like,
he's beaten this guy.
He's beaten that guy.
He's beaten Matt Brown.
He's beaten Johny Hendricks.
I don't.
The belt doesn't mean a thing to me.
It really doesn't.
I just want to see Ken Robbie lawler
beat Tyron Woodley,
Tyron Woodley Beats Robbie lawler.
I start thinking,
okay,
can tyron Woodley beat George St Pierre.
Can you see George St Pierre Ready to
come back?
If he is,
can tyron Woodley beat him or can George
fighter really smart fight all law the
way Rory Mcdonald did and Rory Macdonald
shut down a lot of tyrone's offense in
their fight and won a decision or is
tyron better than he was that I want to
see that.
Is he better?
I want to see is is he's super confident
now that he won the title is he just.
Is he going to take them to some whole
new level?
You got.
You beat a guy like Robbie lawler.
You knock them out and in one round
you've got to think the momentum coming
off of that.
It's got to be stunning.
I would love to see fantasy UFC like a
show where they take maybe the fighters
that have retired or people that aren't
as good as the other fires and have them
like almost do like game shows,
stuff like this.
Like you have to do a game,
go.
Alright.
So this fight you have your shoes tied,
you have to hold a banana and not crush
it.
You have to protect this banana.
Like it's a baby,
you know,
like fun things like that,
you know what I mean?
Like you're saying.
But because I think even as I think as a
fight it would still be fun just to have
other options.
Like almost like a video game,
you know,
where your doctor.
I've told you many times something wrong
with his brain and we need competition.
Still have some kind.
Like there's,
you know,
the fight is still a competition,
but if you take away the belt,
you still maybe want to have like a
tournament a month,
not monthly,
but maybe a quarterly tournament or a
second season of some kind.
So there's something.
Did you ever see,
um,
showtime did
in boxing with the middleweight
division,
that whole,
um,
series of a series of events a few years
back with Carl fraud and bunch of other,
uh,
Andre Ward was in it,
a super six,
is that what it is?
Super Six world boxing classic and it
was super middleweight and they got the
best super middleweights in the world
and they paired them off against each
other and this long running series where
they're all committed to fighting each
other.
It was really interesting,
really interesting as an idea,
like,
as a combat sport idea and you know,
you think about like what that could
mean for the future.
Um,
I think something like that for mma,
mixed martial arts would be gigantic and
it could generate a lot of interest and
it could be something where they put up
a ton of money,
like instead of a world title,
like what have they had an invitational.
What if they,
someone put together an invitation,
they made a deal with the UFC and they
made a deal with,
you know,
um,
one fc or whatever the organizations are
that are valid.
And you have a tournament where they're
all going to duke it out and there's
going to be some sort of split of
revenue of the paper view of this one
tournament and you'll have this super
six type thing like they did with
showtime with boxing.
Be Insane,
man.
That'd be epic.
Isn't fighting for that revenue also?
Maybe good or is that bad?
Because you could have extra problems
with that.
Maybe with people taking dives or
backend deals.
There's whatnot.
I don't know.
I don't know how problems come in with
that,
but
the real money and fighting is always in
winning.
So like getting people to throw fights.
Boy,
that's unusual.
It's so unusual in a high end fighting
because when a fighter loses,
it's not just about losing that fight.
It's also about they lost their last
fight so then they're coming into their
next fight as a loser.
So they're getting less money so people
don't like them as much.
And you know,
if somebody hits you and you just fall
down and pretend that you got knocked
out,
you can't do that.
And you can make money like that.
Somebody could bet you or promise you,
right?
Someone could say,
I'm betting 300 grand and you go down
the first round,
I'll give you a $100,000
for.
I know you're only getting paid 20 grand
and so you do that.
And some dude that has totally been done
in the world of boxing.
It's definitely happened.
I'm sure it's probably happened in the
UFC.
I'm not aware of it happening,
but there's always the potential for
people being deceptive
happened in every sport.
I'm pretty sure at some point or another
at one time.
Yeah.
It wasn't an NBA referee scandal.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Tim,
Donna Hay,
I believe he lied and he went to jail
for it too and he was betting he was
making bets on things that he knew from
insight information,
whether it's like this particular
referee calls really bad against this
team because maybe he doesn't like
someone on the team or something like
that.
They're not supposed to do that,
but he was calling out information
publicly.
I think he wrote a book about it.
All the referees also then said,
he's bullshit.
He's an asshole.
He's obviously a scumbag,
he went to jail,
but when you look at the track records
of some of these things that he was
saying,
it looks to say that there is some way
that there isn't a little bit of water
there,
that he's something so whether or not
try to get that statement of.
So I like to like where people
were talking about.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
that fucking little bit of water in
there.
Huh?
That statement holds water is what I was
trying to say.
So he might've got framed,
I don't know about framed,
but they might.
He,
he definitely got caught and what he was
doing and I think it was betting store,
like maybe what Pete rose did.
Right?
But then he wrote a book afterwards
talking about all this stuff you knew
and all this scumbag shit other referees
were doing.
I'll take your name or anything like
that,
but somebody wanted to talk to him and
see if what other things he knows.
Yeah,
man.
I would imagine if you have something
where people bet on it,
like professional sports or even college
sports,
I would imagine there's so many people
that bet on those games that there's
always going to be like low lives.
Like I know friends who use actual real
old school bookies.
Really?
Yeah,
man.
They use real bookies.
Bookies still exists.
Tim,
Donna Hay,
100 percent of NBA referees gamble when
weird stuff was happening this year in
the NBA.
People always like to say that they're,
uh,
they are setting things up for money and
ratings and whatnot.
And they'll go to wherever he wants to
write an article will go to him and get
a quote from him saying this thing was
fixed or this thing was staged.
And it's unprovable usually,
but he'll say it right.
Should hire amish people or something.
People,
they definitely don't care or have tvs.
Well,
you know what man?
A duh.
The sports fans.
Yeah.
Most sports fans gambled head.
That's another thing that government
fucks a song.
How about that?
You should be able to gamble on whatever
the fuck you want all over town.
And the idea that like money,
one gambling should be taxed and that's
why they're there.
They're trying to keep it this.
Listen,
I didn't earn this money.
I bet you bet money to make money that
is so different than earning money.
You tell me I earned it.
Fuck you.
You Crooks.
Unless it's scratch offs or the lottery
by the government in that case,
gamble,
gamble with a fun logo and a big smile.
And you could win power ball.
It's a power ball.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
Fuck you overlords.
Yeah.
Fuck you for trying to keep weed from
us.
Fuck you.
From the gambling or gambling destroys
families.
Gambling destroys families.
My own family lost everything.
Now he's a retard.
Your uncle was a retard.
Retard lose everything.
They lose it through math.
They lose it through gambling.
They lose through sucking trucker Dick
for crack money.
They lose it through all sorts of ways.
They're fucking crazy.
There's,
there's a certain amount of crazy
people.
You can't blame gambling.
You Fuck 1200 bucks if you win more,
you guys supposed to pay taxes on it.
You can claim losses too.
Which is how some gamblers get through
that,
but oh,
you did claimed losses.
Yeah.
They don't know.
You don't have to say how much you
gambled,
I think throughout a year.
But if you get winnings you can also
claim losses against it.
Wow.
I didn't know that little trick.
Write that down.
Yeah,
it was.
It probably audit the fuck out if you
try to do that.
Do you think you're cute?
Check this out.
Boom.
Going deep in your asshole song.
Look of her receipts.
Do you bring your whole song?
Yeah,
they.
They just have too much power.
They can shut your bank account's down.
They can shut your credit cards down.
They could take and take your money from
your boss before you go to court.
They can do a lot of stuff that they
probably shouldn't be able to do,
but they have to get money from $350.
Million fucking people.
I mean how many paid taxes?
Probably not 300 million.
Right.
And there's so many people that told me
they don't even do taxes.
Like I don't do taxes.
Well,
you're talking to like crazy comedians.
It'll eventually get called exactly,
but you know,
there was a big scandal in Boston that
was one of the.
Shouldn't say scandal was a dilemma.
It was a huge issue in Boston that I got
to experience secondhand.
Fortunately with the old school
comedians that were super successful
there that didn't pay taxes,
it was a giant issue because they got
caught and one got caught and another
guy caught and then the irs people
realized,
oh,
none of these fucking comedians pay
taxes.
How much money these guys are making,
because you'd go to like certain comedy
clubs.
It'd be the same guy like almost every
weekend.
They had like these deals,
like there were certain clubs like
Nick's comedy stop was a big one.
They had deals with the best comics in
town,
so if you went by Nick's comedy,
stop on any given night in the late
eighties you would see like Steve
Sweeney,
Don Gavin,
they would be there every weekend,
so let's.
Places were packed.
They were all getting paid cash or
cooking or originally God,
you have to say allegedly,
allegedly.
I never got offered coke,
but I also never got offered money.
I've never worked there.
Really.
I like,
I'm not going to say who,
but a friend of ours,
like every time you guys just give me
cat.
Yeah,
just give me cash.
Cash.
What the fuck on.
I think I might've worked there once or
twice ever at Nick's,
but I was never in the position where
they get off your coke.
I was,
wasn't in deep enough if I had worked
there was like a I emceed something and
then I came back and worked there,
but that was after like had agents and
they handled the financial part of
things like later,
later on.
But those stories were always there.
Those guys get paid and coke and those
guys get,
you know,
but they just fucking animals.
They were living like savages and they
weren't paying the taxes and they one by
one.
They all got fucking thunderstruck and
it was a worst case scenario because it
was like,
here's the comedy.
Boom.
Okay,
here's like the eighties comedy boom
where everybody's got rolled up sleeves
on fucking blazer and standing onstage.
Did she ever notice and that everybody's
doing that,
they're all killing it,
right?
They're all over the evening at the
Improv.
Can't get enough talent because there's
just not enough comedians.
They just need.
They need more.
They'll shows a huge people love,
like sitting in front of the TV,
like vege not watched an evening at the
Improv.
So these comedy clubs explode all across
the country.
I mean fucking explode.
But as Joey as likes to say that
couldn't cover the spread,
they couldn't cover the spread.
Joe Rogan.
People get tired of seeing the same
fucking act over and over again.
You're going out,
you're buying a fucking babysitter.
And that's what happened.
It died off.
So these guys made all their money in
the hay day and during the day they're
young blown.
I bugged him,
Da da Da da every night killing.
And I told her,
that's not my fucking Dick.
The whole place goes crazy.
The world goes nuts.
They'd fucking clink glasses at the bar.
After awhile they got a Mr Johnson.
It's Mr Peterson from the irs would love
to have a word with you.
Oh Shit.
And then they just go over the fact that
they audited the comedy club and the
comedy club has all these comics on
roster,
you are amongst them.
You made x amount of dollars,
we got paid zero.
You owe as this plus a penalty,
which is that and you just.
And the common cause of dried up and
they're getting older and a lot of tired
that drinking and partying all the time,
you get worn out and then all of a
sudden there's no more work.
The work dies off.
You haven't really done the road so you
don't have a national presence,
you only have a local presence.
And then the fucking money guys come in
and suck it out yet.
So I'm just going to hook the strap to
your spine,
pull the fluid out.
I recently had to go through
all my stuff too for the irs.
And it was.
Nowadays it's a lot better though,
I guess than it used to be because if
you're,
say a comedian,
uh,
you go through and you just go like,
oh,
comedy store.
I was at the comedy store,
I'm a comedian,
you know,
and I go to the comedy store almost
every single day,
but you also realize that everything you
do as a comic like that I could write
off because the parking next door I can
ride off if I even get Netflix,
I could write that off because I'm
researching Netflix,
you know,
and,
and it's pretty amazing like how much
you know you can write off and how much
it's documented nowadays because
everyone's using their cards instead of
paying cash for it.
Right.
So it's,
it's gotten better for comics,
I think,
you know now.
But uh,
yeah,
back then I couldn't even imagine just
having all those receipts and just being
like,
no,
I swear this was for her,
you know,
comedy,
it's kind of screwy because if you're
like a writer,
you can do that to have your writer.
You can say that you're doing research
and you go to the movies
[inaudible]
I don't do that.
I don't know.
I wouldn't.
This is something screwy about it
because like,
yeah,
I guess you could write it off.
I guess it's research,
but really you're just having fun at the
movies,
aren't you?
You know
[inaudible].
I have this business lunches though.
I don't know if you've ever been on tons
of advice to work in restaurants where
people would come in and would use
friendship out of those credit and
quarter stakes
for 15 guys are sitting there drinking
whiskey at lunch.
Yeah,
but not talk about business.
This business in the sense like say like
a Brian and I had a business opportunity
for you and we want you to get excited
about it,
so we're going to take you out.
We're going to get you drunk,
going to buy some steaks and we're going
to sit there and clink glasses together
and will feel a little loose.
We'll have some comradery because of
this.
Booze will be feeling good and we'll go
like,
I like this venture.
I think this could be really successful.
I think we're going to work well
together.
When I have a good fucking diamond
click,
that's a real business
100 percent,
but like in a wolf of Wall Street where
they're sitting there in this data is
looking through all their money they
spent on hookers and whatnot.
You really had to spend $78,000
on data,
but like you could,
we could have had lunch at Mcdonald's or
subway instead of having it at,
you know,
like the ivy or coy or whatever,
and Sushi.
We could've just got food.
Why did you have to spend $500?
You could have spent 100 right while you
guys had to have all the crazy steaks
and $500 bottles of wine to talk about
this meal.
It's the same kind of thought.
Like what kind of fucking logic is that
pussy.
I'm just saying.
I'm crazy.
Crazy.
It's been.
It's been done plenty of times.
I've had friends that make their living
off of,
you're not going to impress me,
but Jamie,
what you're saying is ridiculous.
You're talking about some big,
big business on a budget.
We could have gone to Mcdonald's
supersized.
I'm just sort of making it,
but like if you were going to spend $500
on the client when you can spend five,
well then don't spend any money on your
research to make your job better.
Like just watch,
watch people at the park instead of
paying 10 bucks to get better quality
research.
You know what I mean?
That's all I'm sure that's to watch
people at the park.
It's free.
It's free entertainment and taking in a
movie I was making.
They look like a comics.
Good.
No,
no.
I'm just saying as a comic looking for
material you have.
If you're going to make the argument of
saying I need to get material,
this is what I'm going to do to get my
material.
It could be anything you want to do.
You could talk about basketball.
You could talk about poker to a strip
club joke in your at a park.
Trying to think of strip clubs yet.
That's what I'm saying.
If you want to talk about strip clubs,
you have to go to a strip club.
So at this business guy making this big
deal deal at d at lunch.
He said,
I have to go to this lunch and I have to
spend this money because to try to
impress my clients,
they can't impress,
not Mcdonald's.
There's just.
You can make the arguments if you want
all day long for the thing that is
needed for your business.
Yeah.
That's the only thing I was trying to
say.
Well,
you mean from the employer's point of
view of allowing this to happen or from
the person who's the salesperson needs
to defend this action.
I suppose it's,
yeah,
I,
I could see both arguments,
but honestly I think for a lot of the
people that have those accounts,
like it's kind of important that they
formed these relationships.
That's why business launch is actually
an effective thing,
so I would think that a business lunch
is one of the rare exceptions of
something that makes fun,
that you write off or make sense rather
that you write off.
But I could see that movies make sense.
You know,
like if you're a guy and you're a,
you're writing,
you're a writer and you're writing a
piece about modern horror movies,
about the lack of modern horror movies.
Like if you're a modern,
if you're a fan of horror movies,
fuck.
You have to wait a long time.
How long do you have to wait for a good
goddamn vampire movie?
Hold on for a werewolf movie,
it's every 30 years.
God Damn it.
Every now and then they tease you like
bleeding the ecl del Toro and that were
on the call,
but he's Atari.
He's not going to fuck it up.
This is going to be amazing.
They fucked up Benito del Toro and
Anthony Hopkins and it's still blue.
Nicholas?
Yeah.
That was the worst with Michelle
pfeiffer when she was so hot.
I'll tell you every watched deliverance
the other day.
That's a horror movie.
I can't stop thinking about that.
Squeal.
Like a pig seen.
Ugh.
What a creepy,
realistic version of parts of life that
goes on every single day.
Probably,
probably.
Right.
That was a
crazy ass movie man.
Is that Jack Nicholson?
That is so dumb.
Why is his forehead have zero hair?
Yeah,
he's.
And when,
when he turns into a wolf man,
there is.
He's the same size.
Everything.
It's like,
well,
what do you have more teeth?
Who's that though?
That's not,
that's not him,
right?
That's not Jack Nicholson.
I am.
Is that a different one or is that
another.
A scene in the movie like CGI,
Michelle Pfeiffer.
Jesus.
Who is that Jack made within?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's what he looked like at the end.
So there was like stages of Werewolf
dumb.
Remember this movie?
This is eyes for something.
Oh,
this is different.
Find out if there's a scene where you
see what Jack Nicholson looked like.
I think it was called Wolf.
It was really corny.
They like jumped in slow motion.
Like whenever,
like you're showing slow motion.
First of all,
you fucked up.
Horror movies should be about two
seconds scenes like,
like alien,
like the first movie alien was perfect.
You rarely get to see the alien and when
you did see it it was like when he was a
perfect movie in that sense.
When you see in Jack Nicholson,
who looks exactly like Jack Nicholson
with a thicker beard,
he looks like a Jack Nicholson.
That would be a Barista in a handcrafted
coffee place in Seattle.
That's how fucking furry.
He is.
Always get slightly bigger teeth,
which by the way you can buy,
just like you can buy dental implants,
you can buy those slightly bigger teeth.
So you essentially could look fucking
exactly like Jack Nicholson in this
stupid wolf movie.
You could get some fake eyes where you
put contacts on that make you look
scary.
And uh,
so he's jumping in slow motion.
And as each jumping in slow motion,
you realize like that's just like a
person's body and something,
even though it's not even weird.
It's just a guy like this,
these peanut here.
Remember this movie he peed on James
Spader never.
James before he was in this
new fucking bullshit show isn't.
Huh?
That doesn't look like James Spader at
all.
Was it super?
Nah,
I'm just saying he's way too young.
I guess this old thing go spader.
That's 1984,
right?
I'm not disagreeing.
I'm just saying is it 84 and 94?
Nineteen 94.
Sorry.
Wow.
Ninety four.
Let's see what the wolf part of them
looks like because it was really bad.
I wish I was.
I wish I was like friends with the
people who are doing that.
Moving back when it was happening,
I'd be like,
oh,
she does whatever.
How bad is this going to look?
Come on.
What is she doing?
She's running as the wolf.
Did we miss the transition?
That's like half the Werewolf movie,
man.
Have you got to like Loan Cheney?
See Loan Chaney Jr.
He had an excuse.
Go to tHe wolf man.
The old wolf.
and look at james spader down there.
Look at that handsome wolfelt's.
Look at him.
See that crazy.
That's that dude.
Isn't that blacklist show?
So he drinks a lot of water.
Now go back.
Okay.
Just google loan cheney.
The wolf man.
So that was the wolf man from 2010 that
you just pulled up.
Which is pretty fun.
I put it on the background sometimes
when I'm writing just because it's like
visually it's kind of interesting.
What if the top one,
the top one that's loan cheney as the
werewolf.
So this is like find out what year this
is man,
because this is like,
oh,
this is just a,
an award show.
Um,
he's the classic wolf man.
Now.
See like the monster mash and stuff?
Well,
it was so goofy.
It claude rains.
Nineteen 41 go full screen.
This is exciting.
So this is a trailer for a movie back in
the time where they didn't even have
trailers.
Somebody must've made this after the
fact.
Probably as the wolf man do the
Got bitten by a werewolf.
the werewolf himself don't hand me that.
You're jusT wasting your time.
It will meet you.
Don't hand me that.
You wouldn't want to run away with a
murder.
I killed it.
I killed records.
If I stay here any longer,
you can tell
these special effects.
Good lord.
Look At girls yelling.
Sparely fighting.
Just kinda gave up.
She was psyched.
The blood lust of a savage beast though.
Both.
Man.
I wonder if that's a real trailer of a
fan created.
It looks like a real trailer.
It does,
but I think they had trailers.
Did they have?
Yeah.
Nineteen 41.
They had trailers back then.
Did that.
Really?
Absolutely.
Oh wow.
I didn't think they did man.
I know that for some movies,
like when you go to itunes and you,
uh,
you go to click on trailer for some,
like really shitty movies.
They don't really have a trailer.
They Just take a chunk of the movie,
like stick it in there.
It gives a fucking piece of shit movie.
I did that the other day with some
horror movie and I tried to watch it and
I said,
let me see what the trailer is.
The traiLer wasn't a trailer at all.
It was just like they just took a snip.
What do you want?
Like four minutes.
how long you want the trailer?
Five minutes.
Not five minutes in particular.
It's a good five titty.
If I did,
didn't put that in there.
I mean that's a super common thing.
I didn't know that.
I wonder what year they invented the
trailer.
Have you had to guess?
40 six,
46.
Well that's 41.
30 six.
He six.
It certainly looks like a real trailer.
Like those fonts.
Perfect.
But how bad is the acting?
Even with them?
Murderer.
There's bad acting and movies that I
thought were amazing 10 years ago.
First
shown us fiLm theater in 1913.
Whoa.
That's amazing.
Wow.
And we've been fucked ever since then.
advertising should be illegal,
right?
It's still easy.
It'll fuck with our heads.
I like trailers more than I like movies.
How about that?
Because it's a fucking juicy,
Like they figured out how to make it
into little sound bite.
That's what happened with suicide squad.
Apparently they made that cool trailer
that came out earlier last year and
everyone really liked that.
And uh,
the war on warner brotherS company lists
what I read,
they were afraid it wasn't going to be
that cool.
I wasn't going to look like that.
It wasn't going to deliver on that
promise when they're also freaked out
because of batman and superman that had
failed so hard that they hired that
company that made that trailer to re
edit the movie that the director was
making at the same time they were making
it,
so there's two cuts going around the
same time and then they molded them
together at the end of the summer.
Too many cooks too much come.
They too much in the egg drop soup.
They actually added jokes.
They had to reshoot a lot of stuff to
add more humor to it.
They ended it out the joker completely,
but all you know is that the director's
cuts probably.
They edited out the joker with jared
leto.
They edited a lot of the joker up.
Most of the joker.
He's barely in that movie.
I really.
I refuse to watch.
You heard.
No,
no.
I read it.
I ride him.
He read
so true.
He complained about it to.
Oh man,
he's not even in the poster.
He look dope.
Did you notice that he's not even in the
post or one of the main characters as
well?
In all fairness,
who the fuck knows what happened?
You know this jared leto character?
Who knows what kind of wacky shenanigans
he was up to.
He was going to send an.
We're doing weird stuff for the cast and
character the whole time.
Oh,
was he pissed them off?
I don't know about the cast.
He was just supposedly who's just became
an issue.
I don't know if that happened.
Yeah,
there you go.
I can that coming.
I read somewhere.
I don't know if it's true if will smith
saying that I didn't research it,
but I read that will smith hates him and
he like,
like publicly said he hates him.
Jared leto.
Yeah.
Wow.
If willsmith hates you,
but I don't know if it's true though
about the rock yesterday coming out
publicly talking about it.
Fast and furious.
Eight cast mates that were being divas
onset when it was causing a big rift and
all of his classmates and closed like
kurt russell's tyrese,
a vin diesel obviously isn't it?
A couple of people.
He didn't publicly say who it was,
but the way it came out,
it was like an instagram post and so
everyone got a hounding all of his
classmates asking who it was and what
was really going on.
It turns out it was vin diesel and they
like had it out in his trailer
yesterday.
What was going on with vin diesel?
He's showing up late to set.
He's a producer on the movie though too,
so he's done.
It makes a lot of money on these movies.
Yeah,
he wear sunglasses
side.
That's always the weirdest thing with
sunglasses.
You can do that.
If you're p diddy,
there's like certain people that can do
that.
You can't do that.
Vin vin diesel this fast.
Eight p,
if it was reportedly vin diesel.
The rock was calling a candy ass.
This is the best fire up promotion of a
film that has diesel's a large
gentleman,
but I would bet everything I've ever
made on the gentleman to the right with
a goatee,
like everything,
everything.
I know me too.
I've ever made my life the future of the
world itself.
I bet it on the rock.
The rocks.
Awesome.
He's,
well,
he's an inspirational character too.
Like,
um,
he's a dude who gets up in the fuck.
What does it say?
The rock walks back,
his name calling,
but vin diesel lives for drama.
Hmm.
I don't know what that means.
He said he may maybe just relaxed and
said,
what am I doing?
Why am I wasting my time here?
It is.
Why?
I mean,
he's the number one most highly paid
actor in the world.
He's number one.
So,
uh,
you know,
this is going to be drama.
There's going to be people that fuck
with you when you're number one.
There's that.
There's gonna be issues you have working
with some dude.
And there's also probably a lot of
bullshit stories that are put into the,
into the tmzs just so you have some
prior advertising of a movie that no one
even knew it was being filmed.
You know,
This isn't even a tmc.
Right?
This was his own instagram page.
So it was,
you can say that they're doing it on
purpose.
Yeah.
I mean,
especially the rocks is such a prankster
anyways,
you know,
so it's,
that's a good point.
That's good point.
Call to do to candy as does sound like
pro wrestling talk.
I don't trust anything anymore.
Like for,
for the longest time I don't trust.
I don't.
I used to think rotten tomatoes was
completely legit.
Right.
but then you start seeing movies on
rotten tomatoes and you're like,
I saw that movie.
There's no way.
That's a 98 percent.
How in the fuck is that?
Ninety eight percent.
Then I heard from somebody that they
only pick the top comic art.
Our top reviewers,
uh,
they don't use the same reviewers for
every movie.
So like they'll have like 10 top
reviewers for this movie and only five
for this movie.
Like they're almost picking and choosing
them mean and we're talking about.
We found out that it's like who owns
rotten tomatoes?
And viacom ownS rotten tomatoes come up.
Fandango.
Fandango is owned by universal and
universal is owned by comcast and
universal and universal and sony like.
Anyways,
so that come to the terrordome come on
down and all that,
all that fucking thing is is selling tv
shows and movies that have.
They make those.
Okay,
but doesn't rotten tomatoes operate
under user?
Like use your criticism say let's say
like it uses the top reviewers.
Yeah.
Like there's 100 reviewers that they
choose from.
They choose from.
Yeah.
They don't use the same reviewers for
every movie I've been looking like,
like,
like say like you're recommend a minimum
wage.
So you're saying they choose a review as
well.
The same reviewers,
they're not reviewing every movie.
Are they?
Is there like an an industry and
reviewing things?
Well,
what if you look at say like,
let's see what movies come out.
Sausage party right now.
Look at the who's reviewed that movie?
TheN look at a movie that's also opening
this friday.
See how many of those reviewers are the
same?
They're not the same reviewers.
One the time.
One hundred percent.
Many people reviewing a movie on rotten
tomatoes,
like when they give those tomato
numbers,
how many people are doing that?
We thousands.
No,
they only.
Well,
they have user reviews and then they
have like professional reviewers,
85,
74 reviews.
Right,
right.
Wait a minute.
Oh,
this is a critic's consensus.
Yes.
And the minute it wasn't always that
way.
Yes.
And separated through critics and then
use the reviews and there's been like a
separate icon that you're supposed to
pay attention.
I was just gO to the app.
Right.
And then if you scroll down now if you
scroll down,
they have lights.
Actually yelp go to the yelp app.
But I'm good at rotten tomatoes was even
have an app.
Do they make that up?
yeah,
they did.
But then they have like the reverse.
And then a lot of these reviewers,
there's somebody that actually chooses
if it's rotten or not.
I clicked on a few of these,
uh,
like what they're called fresh reviews
where it's supposed to be positive
review and then they go through it.
You're like,
how did they get positive from this?
This sounds like they were kind of on
the fence,
like a 50 slash 50 percent,
you know?
But then it's like all,
none of it makes real sense.
There's no real math on this at all.
It's it's,
it's pretty bullshit because there's
been a few interesting that you Just
pointed that out.
Yeah.
It's interestinG that that's critics.
I really thought that the whole purpose
of those things was reviewers being
regular peopLe.
Yeah.
If you look at it like a site like
metacritic,
that seems like it's a little bit less
bias and a more faCtual and that makes
more sense because there's been so many
movies on your lately.
I've been like,
That's impossible that that's a 90
percent.
Yeah,
because you could,
if you had a movie,
you could just use these guys.
Take them to business.
Lunch plank length,
a credit card.
I just went to their website and they're
owned by cbs interactive.
Nevermind.
God it.
I had no idea that that's interact.
If you motherfuckers that's viacom were
buttons sold.
Ladies and gentlemen look like,
look at this now.
If you go to this one and look at the
same movies like sausage party or
whatever it is,
it won't match up.
Shouldn't they match up?
If they both do the exact same fucking
thing in their own farm,
the same company.
Oh,
I hate life.
That owned by the same company.
One of them is owned by cbs.
The other one is owned by universal.
Right.
But yet notice how many.
How many reviewers on this one compared
to how many reviewers on the one that's
universal with sony universal work
together if not owned by the same
company.
Right.
How many different.
What is the.
Was the numbers for metacritic?
Seventy four versus would've met a
critical
less.
Yeah.
This is for critic reviews.
They have 27,
six,
30,
34 or so,
just 34.
So my folks,
we had to get medicated.
So metacritic is not the same pool as
rotten tomatoes where all these extra
reviewers coming from.
Rotten tomatoes on a movie that you guys
are a bunch of people that are,
you know,
look,
if you had,
let's say there's a network,
right?
Like okay,
there's a network of podcasters,
right?
We're all kind of whether or not we're
networked together
officially.
We're all connected,
right?
Well,
you know,
kind of movie reviewer type characters
that are like online movie movie
reviewer dudes.
If they say,
hey man,
you want to get in with this rotten
tomatoes thing,
it's really cool.
You just,
you have to go to seven movies a week
and get paid really well and you just
write these little things about it and
you know,
you're encouraged to support the big
ones.
Just be fair in your criticism.
You don't have to make things up if you
don't like something,
just be fair.
Okay,
cool.
And then you go in there and then you
got steady money.
You got steady money coming your Way.
I don't know how much it is,
but I would imagine a company like
rotten tomatoes,
which you've used,
I've used so many people have used to to
see a movie.
They probably makes a cash,
right?
Oh yeah.
Have to.
They have to.
Everybody knows it.
Yeah.
Who doesn't know about rotten tomatoes,
right?
I mean they advertise movies on rotten
tomatoes that they judge that same kind
of weird.
Well,
the problem is even if it was like
totally legit in the beginning,
right after,
which I believe someone that comes along
with you,
like even the fertittas sold the ufc.
Okay.
Just be aware lIke it's at a certain
point in time,
no matter how rich you are,
someone comes along with a good number.
Okay.
Say,
okay,
so,
uh,
we'll still be able to review movies.
I can be honest.
You can be fair.
Can you be fair?
I can be fair.
have you ever be fair?
Let's do this.
Let's go on a business level.
Yeah.
Exynos chip.
Stay.
No.
Mcdonald's.
kayla.
We're going to be a business forever.
We,
we're going to die some day.
We're not dying,
bro.
We're not fucking die and we're going to
take hormones and we're going to go to a
fucking doctor in Brazil and he's going
to shoot us up at the same shit that
they shot up.
Michelle pfeiffer when she looks
perfect,
she looks really similar to how she
looks in that wolf
go math right now.
I just saw her in person.
The other Is 12.
She's 12 years old.
She's so small and so tiny person.
what's wrong with you that you know,
it's so weird.
I,
they really gave me.
I got to go to the sausage party premier
and I got to be on like the red carpet,
all the celebrities and stuff and it was
really,
it was my first time ever doing
something like that level,
but I got to see everyone in person that
I've always seen like selena gomez and
and that.
josh,
what's that guy's name again?
Josh from limitless or Joseph Gordon
levitt,
george.
All these guys that I've seen so many
times.
They're so small and like in real life,
it's so weird seeing them.
They seem like little versions of
everyone.
It's so cool.
It's cool and interesting.
Well,
you're not a big guy.
Yeah,
my side.
I know.
But you,
you think,
I guess because you think of them as
superheroes,
you know,
and a lot of these movies and stuff
that,
that
if I had a dollar for every time someone
said,
you're shorter than I thought you'd be
to me,
I'd have $100.
$100.
I'm not kidding.
Right.
Michael?
Sarah,
by the way,
he was the weirdest guy.
Michael.
Sarah,
who's a kick ass.
Is that it's called that guy or no?
No.
Scott pilgrim.
Remember scott pilgrim?
Oh yeah.
He was weird.
Yeah,
he.
Well,
he just looked guys weird.
You always.
He just has a weird vibe domain.
It's like a.
It's probably a little uncomfortable.
That's why he's funny.
Yeah.
Hipster like homeless.
Hipster.
That's what he looked like in the
sixties.
That dude is so funny.
I love that guy.
I think that whenever someone's at
funny,
I always assumed that something going on
some kind of crazy.
You know?
He's that funny.
He's a funny fucking guy,
man.
Absolutely.
Kick ass.
It's still one of my or not.
Not kept pilgrims.
Scott pilgrim.
Yeah,
it's super bad.
Super bad is my favorite.
It's like that scene when jonah hill's
just drawn dixon school.
I remember I was literally like lie.
I watched it by myself and I was lying
sideways on my couch kicking and
paddling in the air,
like drawing,
like why you keep drawing?
That's something I would totally have
done.
I still do it.
To this day,
half the nopa.
This has no.
David choe,
Whatever david chosen here.
He's drawing dicks.
Yeah,
I love that.
He's got all different colored tags.
So perfect.
Dick's,
dick's,
boobs and eyeballs were my three.
Was it jonah hill that did it?
It wasn't him.
It was jonah hill.
God,
it's so fucking funny,
man.
So jonah hill?
Yep.
Cool.
Sausage party.
Funny.
Be honest.
Don't rotten tomatoes falling out.
I'll tell you the tell you the
full truth.
I've been waiting for this movie for a
long ass time because it's kind of like
a dream movie,
a pixar movie and having a dirty,
like an old fritz,
the cat or something.
Right.
And you know,
there's a couple of scenes in there that
kind of our fun,
very,
very fun to watch.
But overall it just,
it was just like having a kids movie
where they cussed at and it was like,
you know,
really kind of like,
oh god,
oh jeez.
Oh my.
I got bored.
That was the biggest thing.
I just got really bored while watching
it and I was not expecting.
I was expecting that to be the best way
to get tattoo of it on my arm or
something,
but no,
it was,
it was one of the biggest letdowns I've
ever had and the rotten tomatoes,
that's called reality.
Internet's coming for your son and I
love seth rogen movies.
That's my favorites.
Like,
like if there was a Class of movie,
if seth rogen movies are my top
favorite,
but it just didn't like it was cheesy,
like they called the juice juice and
there's like all these like things Where
you're just like,
oh god.
It's like open mic night.
Oh man.
Brian coming down hard on the sausage
party.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I really,
maybe I was just a little bit of a
correction.
Maybe I waS just in the mood.
I will definitely watch it again and see
if it.
It seemed like a kids movie where they
cussed and it's pretty much like if I'm
going to do the first or like a new
version of like an adult cartoon I'm
going to show or nudity,
I'm going to get that nc 17 rating.
I don't get on underrating.
I'm going,
I'm going deep.
Okay.
You know,
but you know,
that's not what they were trying to do.
I mean,
they,
they do it in movie.
Spoiler alert.
You don't,
don't,
don't.
I'll change it.
Then the movie ends very graphic.
Does it end.
Is graphic is like team America world
police when they're fucking.
It goes over it.
But imagine if it was made for cinemax.
Oh,
okay.
I've seen nipple,
but no,
no lips.
These are all just pieces of lettuce and
tacos and stuff.
Oh,
there's,
that's what I'm saying.
They should have.
Don't say anymore.
You've already confused me enough where
I can forget what you said and you just
cross it off to you being you.
Right.
But no,
I mean it's unfortunate.
You know what man?
It's.
Did you see ghostbusters?
Fuck no.
Okay.
Here's,
here's my thinking.
Did you?
Yes,
I did.
God,
my girls want to see it.
All right.
It's perfect movie for her year old
girl.
It's a perfect movie for an eight year
old girl.
That's my review.
Had she seen the original kind of scary.
She doesn't have to.
Here's the thing about.
Here's the thing about watching
ghostbusters in new form,
if the original didn't exist,
it's kind of a fun movie.
It's stupid.
There's some giant leaps.
There's some.
There's some kind of clunky writing,
but there's also some funny shit.
There's some funny moment I heard it was
all man hating and ends with not all man
hating,
but definitely a lot of man hating.
There was definitely every move.
Every dude in the movie was a dork,
but it's not the only one who was really
unbelievable that.
Well,
like literally wasn't believable.
Was chris hemsworth the guy?
Yeah,
it was awesome.
It was really good.
I heard it was awesome.
It was really funny,
but he's
so stupid in the movie that it's
unbelievable and these girls are like
constantly enamored with him in love
with them,
but they can't believe how dumb he is
and that's like sort of this running gag
to the point where it's almost
ridiculous.
But here's what I think.
I think if that bothers you,
what kind of a bitch are you like that's
really bothering you?
That these women are shitting on men to
the point where they're taking chris
hemsworth and they're making them dumb
kit at all.
The dumb bitches that had been in
movies.
Can't we have one movie where these
three,
you know,
not so good looking girls take over the
fucking world and,
and save everybody and,
and have the dudes be all fucked up
looking or a or a mass or crazy or chris
hemsworth and chris hemsworth was
perfect and beautiful.
Also like the dumbest human being that's
ever walked the face of the planet and
an actor showing his head shots like the
whole deal.
You like super cliche.
So I never go to the movies anymore
because of the problem I'm having with
things like ghostbusters though and
stuff where the hype doesn't live up to
the movie.
The movie sucks so bad.
I can't believe I didn't have to suck.
That was my point.
Yeah.
It didn't have to suck,
but like there was some funny shit in
the movie.
I don't want to give away any parts of
it.
Were there,
there was some like clever turns in the
beginning of the movie where I laughed.
I was like,
this,
this is funny.
This is funny,
and I thought of myself.
I was trying to watch that movie saying,
if I saw this movie without having known
about the first movie,
what would I think about it?
Especially because I'm taking my kids.
Right?
It's a good movie to take kids to.
It's fun.
Silly.
It's kind of scary,
like whoa,
but it's obviously really fake,
but it's.
It wasn't that bad.
It wasn't a point where anybody would
get mad.
The only reason why anybody got mad is
because it's a redo of the original
ghostbusters and it's all women instead
of all men.
Everybody got fucking terrified or angry
or frustrated or pissed or who's fucking
social justice warriors.
My thought is who gives a fuck?
Like is that really a concern that
they've decided to try to make money by
reducing ghostbusters with chicks?
Like isn't that an obvious thing?
I thought,
I thought.
I think the biggest concern for me
lately with movies is the stories aren't
there.
We're just looking at so much cgi and
tricks that they need to really think
about like,
holy shit,
what the fuck was the plot of this
movie?
Will that was ghostbusters?
Yeah,
definitely.
There was definitely part of that.
There was also some really clunky
writing there.
Something like that,
like with the point where yoU saw them
in some scenes early on.
They're really fun and unexpected and
light fun kind of scenes like,
this is kind of fun.
This movie's kind of fucking weird.
It's like it's not a bad movie,
and then you're like,
oh,
but it's kinda bad.
Here we.
This part's kind of bad.
It's all like a bunch of different
movies.
It's not like if you go back and watch
like a pick a classic movie,
like if you go Watch the outlaw josey
wales,
the outlaw josey wales is the outlaw
josey wales froM minute one to the time
of the end of the movie.
It doesn't vary in the way it feels.
It feels like the outlaw josey wales.
It's a beautiful work of art.
It's seamless iN its production,
like the way it portrays everything is
the same through the whole movie and it
builds up and it makes you feel like
you're really engrossed in,
gripped in it.
ThiS movie didn't do that.
This ghostbusters movie would take you
in and pull you away and take you to
push you away from it.
It was like,
it would be so clunky at tiMes.
You'd be like,
what?
Like this is the same movie that did
that youtube thing earlier.
That was so hilarious.
Is the same movie.
How did,
how did,
how did this get through?
Did you guys just who,
who gave you?
Did you guys get shitty notes?
Like what happened?
I want to know what happened cause like
if that goes buster Movie came out and
it was all checks but it was fucking
bang and just hold clarius like what is
that movie that all the girls love that?
I haven't seen it.
The hilarious bridesmaids and something
bad.
Bad mom.
No,
that's a new one.
There's an old one.
Something bridesmaids that kristen wiggs
in it too.
Yes.
That movie's supposed to be fucking
hilarious.
I have not seen it,
but like a lot of people that have seen
it that I respect as comedians have
said,
do that movie is fucking hilarious.
I think berman is god.
I might just put words in his mouth.
Maybe it was joy.
Did you see this?
The neW independence?
Of course not.
Fuck that.
How long does that last awful.
When I saw.
How long did that last?
The movie theater.
Oh,
a day at least.
I mean it has to last at least a week or
two
spoken independence day enough.
Capital e,
dash nef.
It's weird because I buy movies on
itunes now.
You know,
like I instead of like when it's not on
netflix and hulu,
I'd rather spend 10 bucks and buy it on
itunes,
then go to a movie and spend 50,
you know,
on everything.
So I buy a lot of movies now in so many
movies that I'm like,
I've heard nothing but good things about
this.
Maybe I'm like,
god damn,
I wasted 10 buCks on that fucking like
what?
Give me an example.
Oh fuck you like 10 cloverfield lane.
No,
I haven't seen that,
but I,
that's one of the ones.
I'm not a problem.
I'll be about to endorse it and
recommend it to you,
but I hate it.
some people hated it.
Did you sit iN the theater?
No.
So at home,
do you like seeing movies in the theater
or action movies specifically?
Do you think that's important to see
them there versus at home?
Unless your p digitally.
I mean like when you got some gigantic
ass fucking house with a movie theater
and it,
you're not going to get the same effect
of the sound.
I think the when when someone is a
composer,
like let's take for example,
like certain movies that have amazing
soundtracks and like you hear things
happening behind you.
Like The most recent star wars movie
soundtrack was incredible and like this,
all these,
there's all this shit going on.
It's part of the experience.
You'll wash this giant ass fucking
screen.
It'S beautiful.
Crystal clear.
The sound is incredible.
Literally feels like it's coming from
everywhere in the room.
You can't reproduce that at home.
so in that case,
I think that yeah,
for some kinds
of movies watching it in a movie theater
is.
But how about a country with no country,
no country for old men that's totally
unnecessary.
Watch that movie in the movie theater,
we don't need to require that.
That's.
It's not a big sound movie though to
sound is required and whatnot.
But like it's not.
There's no big sound elements in it.
Right?
It's awesome.
Some movie that might be better if you
absorb it by yourself,
you don't want to be influenced by
anybody because it's such a movie that
makes you think so much.
Like even the end of it,
the individual sort of a,
I don't want to give it away,
but it's a very strange ending,
but it's one of the best movies I've
ever seen.
But it's one of those movies where as
you're watching it,
you're like in gripped,
you're just,
it's,
it takes you to this place and you don't
want to be distracted in any way when
you're dealing with this.
Like it's not doing anything you
expected to do.
It's doing all sorts of weird shit.
Like it's a,
it's very different than a lot of movies
and a lot of movies that have this very
specific formula that even if they get
creative inside that formula,
they still stick to the formula and the
good guy wins in the end and all that
stuff happened.
This movie is not like that at all.
None.
No country for old men took me like a
couple of years to really appreciate
what it was all about because I saw it.
I was like,
god,
they acting is so good.
The story so compelling.
But what is,
what is missing in this thing?
Well,
it's missing this.
It's not tidy.
It's like this just spectacular work of
drama.
So much shit going on.
It just leaves you with this feeling of
whoa at the end of it,
you know?
And I think that,
you know,
movies like that,
that's a,
that's a rare accomplishment to like
they.
I mean it's,
it's sort of like what we're talking
about,
Michael Phelps being so incredible.
It's something that everybody could do.
Like it's,
there's,
there's all kinds of movies that are
awesome,
and then every now and then you get a
movie that makes you go,
whoa,
I got complete.
redefiner are
super rare,
but when it happens,
when you hear that,
the last five that aren't that like,
here's the last five I bought,
that sucked and everyone told me it was
an amazing movie inside out,
which is a pixar movie.
Loved it.
Wow.
Dora kidS loved it.
I read stories to them every night and
modulated.
Gosh,
you liked it.
So you liked that.
Shut down my body's testosterone
adapters.
And I sit in this seat as a daddy and
shit.
I live my life through a.
How dare you,
how dare you mock him while he cries in
albuquerque.
Um,
and uh,
while,
uh,
you know,
enjoy it from their eyes.
They enjoy it.
They think it's a legacy.
I hang out with a six year old that you
love dearly child that you know,
for kids.
I agree 100 percent definitely.
But if it was by myself and go,
shut the stupid fucking shit off.
Yeah,
the worst I like,
I have a theory that if you're on for
you,
if you're on depression medicine,
it's like the best movie ever,
and I've heard people saying,
I've cried five times in that movie as
the kid.
You might cry.
Yeah.
Uh,
another one in a million ways to die in
the west west.
One of the worst piles of shit
I've ever seen in my life.
Set mcfarland's movie where he's in the
west and a seth macfarlane family guy.
He made a movie.
Yeah.
Is he the actor?
Everyone told me that was great and I
fucking hated it.
Oh,
I know they're setting the toP 10 posts.
Either it could wreck your brain and
start thinking,
man,
fuck cartoons.
I'm ready to sling this dick in front of
the camera.
Says he's too smart.
He's too much of a bad motherfucker.
Seth macfarlane number and his ass the
night before,
the night before.
What's that?
Everyone told me that was a great movie.
I haven't heard of that.
It's a seth macfarlane.
Maybe that I forgot.
I bought that.
It was really horrible,
but that's the main.
Yeah,
girl,
she's hot.
Charlie's,
they're wrong.
No,
that's not a the wrong what's going on
with her face.
That's not real photoshop poster a
little bit.
So why would they do that?
You take one of the most beautiful women
in the world
and you alter her to make her look like
some modern day playmate.
That's so stupid.
That wasn't eric.
That's deciphered.
Oh,
okay.
Well there you go,
bitch.
Take that back.
There she goes,
charlene.
Yeah.
Come on man.
That can't really be at 33 percent
rotten tomatoes.
Somewhat dated payday payday bills.
Why tomatoes needs that paper,
ted to speak.
If you want more than 33.
well,
you know,
we thought we could have business
swatch.
We'll have a trach rotten tomatoes.
Turn into a gangster from new jack city
titties.
Have a meeTing,
a business meeting.
I put it on my platinum card.
Now you'd have a black card if you're a
real ball.
You okay?
Black card?
Yeah,
but she had a black card.
I think it'd be cool if When my sister
comes over and her fucking husband
starts bragging about his business,
he pull all your black card.
Bb back card.
You know,
it's a good maybe for kids,
so I think it's one of my favorite
animated ones are not the zootopia.
I think he's like,
I'm seth motherfucking macfarlane.
I don't need a goddamn black card.
Okay.
Are you like a regular car?
It's ironic.
I have a flip flip phone.
I drive a mini cooper seth macfarlane.
I made the valet guy.
You bet that.
How much success is that guy?
He's great.
I like him.
He is an awesome.
I met him.
He's a super busy high times of words.
I've met him twice.
That was a,
I don't know.
I don't think we met him then.
Dude.
Yeah,
I think we met.
Um,
seth rogen.
do you?
You're with seth rogen?
Yeah.
I met seth mcfarland at his place
because I did a voice,
like a fear factor voice on one of the
shows.
I wasn't american dad,
I think.
Yes.
But he's a super
nice guy.
Super nice guy.
He's like,
he,
he's laughing.
He goes,
we just smoked pot and come up with
funny shit.
If that was his,
like he was like super easy to get along
with,
like really friendly.
I did the thing for them.
I said,
thanks man,
I'm really nice to meet you.
Like super friendly and nice,
and I was like,
wow,
that's cool to you know,
a lot of times you meet these super
genius characters.
They're awkward and yellow.
Don't make this guy annoyed,
you know,
here's what I'm.
Some super genius guy that created some
sitcom,
try to be nice to them.
I don't know,
you don't know what you're dealing with.
But like so far I've met a lot of those
guys that some of them work on like paul
centers and one of the first guy that
ever,
like there was a guy produced news
radio,
the first guy to give me like my big
break in hollywood.
He when I met the first time I met him.
Like this guy is like way too smart and
way too weird.
Like I don't want to piss him off
because I want this job.
Like I don't even know what to say.
This dude,
you know,
there's a certain like super genius type
characters like show runner type dudes.
They're notoriously like powerful
figures.
Like who's that guy that like charlie
sheen got into it with that was a sitcom
creator.
What does that dude's name?
Chuck lorre.
Yes.
That guy is the mac daddy of those shows
like no one has run more of those
fucking gigantic smash.
Super $100,
million billion dollar hits.
Then that guy who sounds lIke a handsome
person.
Well,
he's just a.
He just knows how to do those kind of
shows.
You know,
like he's a guy who's figured out like a
frequency.
He's figured out.
He's gotten more shit.
Really?
Yeah.
two and a half men and greg.
Civil grace under fire.
Big bang theory mom for an eastern.
What?
The fucks for anything since 1992.
What he was learning,
he was learning grace unDer fire was a
big one.
There was a crazy rumor that I.
I can't really talk about too much about
brett butler from grace under fire at
the cool guy in the top left.
What's his face telling nigger on?
He died recently.
Oh,
did,
that's right.
He was a super nice guy telling
negroland came up to me after one of my
sets one night and was like,
uh,
like one of the,
one of the nicest compliments,
but also like really honest and,
and curious.
Like we had like a reallY cool
conversation.
I was like,
this is the least hollywood conversation
between two men that do the same
business in hollywood ever.
He was like super honest about like
subject matter.
We were talking about like,
um,
like he,
he said that he's always wondered like
what should we talk about on stage?
And he's sometimes he's confined
himself.
He was saying that he wondered or
worried whether or not the audience
would appreciate his own.
The things that he thought were
interesting.
So instead he was writing and talking
about stuff that he thought that they
would think would be interesting and
that he was trying to change that.
So we had this really interesting talk
about it,
but he died really suddenly have like a
weird disease I think.
What age,
age,
not that old man to look up.
Taylor negron liver cancer.
He'd passed away january of last year.
How old was he?
FIfty seven.
If I can hang in there 10 years.
We got that 10 years from now to 10
years is quick.
Summer fucking came and went so fast and
it's not even over yet.
What the fuck happened?
This summer was august 11.
It's fucking flying.
I refuse to believe that time is the
same every day.
I refuse to believe I don't give a fuck
about your watches.
I don't care about your quartz
movements.
I don't care about your atomic clock.
I think it's moving faster.
I agree.
One hundred percent.
I would have bet anything on it.
It makes zero sense.
let's all bet.
$5.
Okay.
Since you said he'd bet everything on
it.
I'm putting you money on the table,
fella.
All right,
let's go to the carpet.
Tell us the answer.
Jamie.
Times moving faster.
One of the things that I was.
I was watching this thing on on planets
and about the expansion of the universe
and not only the expansion,
but the fact that it's accelerating.
It's moving apart faster and faster and
that they dIdn't know this 20 years ago
and I was listening to this guy speak
about it and I remember thinking to
myself like,
that is so crazy,
like that is a huge factor in our
existence that this universe is not just
static but it's moving away and it's
accelerating in some sort of strange way
and that they can measure it when they
measure it over 10 or 20 years is a
measurable number that allows them to
discern like,
okay,
we were positive that this thing is not
just moving but accelerating and this is
our universe and they just figured that
out 20 years ago.
like we're just waking up.
It's like we're on a starship and we're
flying through the university.
We just came out of hyperspace and we're
all like,
okay,
where are we going?
What is,
what's,
what is this?
Okay?
Does anybody have a manual?
Here's the manual.
We're going to go look through the shit
that the old people wrote down.
We literally are exactly the same thing.
Like we get taught by people who get
taught by people who get taught by
people who are basically monkeys,
you know,
it was like,
this is like a few chains away from us
and dudes with sticks trying to kill
giraffes and shit.
There's not that many.
If you Go back in time like numbers,
you wouldn't get Like 20,
30 times and then you're in the caveman
era.
That shit is not that far ago,
man.
It's not that far ago.
So we're like waking up in the middle of
like this trip,
this whole galaxy hurling through the
universe going a thousand miles an hour
and a circle flying around a huge
nuclear explosion a million times bigger
than it just flying through the universe
and we're waking up and we're going,
what about gay marriage?
Fuck that.
Not on my watch,
bro.
Okay,
okay.
Okay.
What do you think about taxes?
WeLl,
we need to revamp the entire tax rates
and we did russell's book and you'll get
to where your powdered wig and
meanwhile flying through infinity and we
just realizing it.
We're just like,
oh,
we're not.
Not only is the son not the center of
the universe,
not only is the earth not the center of
but this galaxy is just one of hundreds
of billions.
There's untold numbers.
Not only that,
but inside each galaxy is a supermassive
black hole that's one half of one
percent of the mass of the entire
galaxy,
and if you go through that,
there might be an unlimited number of
universes.
How the planetS are lined up.
Right now we're getting some sweet
pitchers from mars.
Have you seen those?
Dude,
that one.
What else I've seen mad about you,
chuck lorre knocking it out of the park,
making,
making cash.
He's got a tube right at Thailand,
has a tube and he presses a green light
and the hotness,
young prostitute you've ever seen in
your life goes through that.
This is not true.
That's totally sheen.
I got confused.
Charlie sheen would do that.
Charlie sheen probably did.
That was two and a half men money.
He's almost out of money.
Supposedly.
He's almost spent the last amount of
money.
That's not true.
I heard it.
I Just read that he's like really
hurting,
like he's cutting this money up from his
ex wife.
Like he used to give her so much money
around.
Cut it all off.
Oh no.
I mean,
well he is a,
he's got hiv and he does a lot of drugs.
Those are not good things to have
together.
I mean like everybody was on his side
when that whole thing went down with
that chuck lorre guy that chuck lorre
guys like this.
He's a real simple man.
Money iS tight.
I can't pay ridiculous child support.
Well,
that might be a tmz headline by the way.
Fifty $5,000
a month.
Wow.
Wonderful.
Charlie had been raking in six,
13 a month just from his cut of two and
a half men profits.
Wow.
Six hundred.
$13,000
a month.
Gotcha much.
I recently had a sell those rights for a
lump sum of 26 million.
Seven hundred $50,000.
He is suffering.
That is a smile pittance for a man of
his esteem to live off.
First of all,
how dare they,
how dare they only give him $26 million.
He doesn'T say what happened to the
stash.
Charlie says he now averages $87,000
a month and last month got a relatively
paltry $6,261.
He says he now can't keep up because his
monthly expenses total $105,000
and $25,000
for healthcare expenses not covered by
any insurance.
Twenty $5,000
a month for healthcare expenses.
Is that what you call your drug dealer?
Oh,
allegedly.
Allegedly.
Maybe he's just got a fucking Michael
Jackson type dude.
Put them to sleep at night.
Just every lease amount by Michael
Jackson.
Dude,
that dude slipped.
I ain't going to slip baby.
I got your back on my hold.
You.
I'm going to be with you.
I'm going to put you under every night.
Different shit.
I got different shit.
The shit did michael jackson's doctorate
use.
It was a good idea.
In theory.
Here's why it doesn't work in practice.
It doesn't allow you to go to heavy rem
sleep.
My stuff does.
Okay.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to
take you to the.
I'm going to drop you out of the alpha
spate into beta state and then you go
and you're like,
okay.
Okay.
Okay,
cool.
Cool.
I'm charlie cina.
Look,
I'd love to talk to you,
But there's a fucking,
uh,
a bowling ball bag filled with coke and
five strippers and the other room I kind
of go to work.
If you could guess a nuMber,
how many people do you think are being
put to sleep?
Not daily,
but like semi daily or we did that way
to,
to two a day.
RIght?
Like thousands of people.
100 people need heavy sedation by maybe
a dog.
There's a lot.
I know several people that are really
nice,
folks that need adderall,
not adderall.
Ambien to go to bed meet you.
They're not drug addicts.
They work jobs that are very stressful.
they have a very nice families.
there's nothing wrong with them.
Do you notice they love that stuff?
Do you know?
It's mostly women though.
I find that,
yeah.
really?
I know it seems like every girl I know
either is taking over the counter,
like what's the stuff that's in a good
on it stuff?
New mood.
Five htp.
Yeah.
No,
no.
The one that makes a trip trip to law or
they're taking,
they're supposed to make you relax.
Uh,
but everyone,
every girl I know it has something to
help her sleep almost,
you know,
consider what you just said.
first of all,
I know those are hanging around and slip
this on grazing and it a bad.
Anybody be crazy.
We need everybody.
It's like that song it takes to put
sleeping issues just seems really big.
Yeah.
But you're dealing with a very biased
study group.
Oh yeah.
I know.
Yeah.
Some people sleep like babies bro.
They can't wait to sleep,
but no guys.
Alright.
Yeah.
I don't take,
I've never taken a sleeping pill.
I know guys.
Yeah.
It's weird when you don't have like
regular life job.
Yeah,
true.
And I just pretty much go to sleep when
I go to sleep now.
Yeah.
I know guys with a lot of serious
obligations that oftentimes will work 10
to 12 hours a day all the time.
Like I have a good buddy of mine,
he needs it.
He works 10,
12 hours a day.
He has hIs own business and he's always
working and he's fucking exhausted and
sometimes he's like,
ah,
what about the accounts and what about
this and that,
and he'll take an ambient and pop off
and I feel like now all I have to do is
just eat and I'll fall asleep for like,
I don't know what it means.
Like last night I had chicken wings and
I fell asleep like men child.
Do you know about their child's brian?
No.
I mean it's like I don't understand
these people like I guess we have jobs
and they don't sleep.
Whatever funnel I could sleep,
I don't get it.
Food does not gIve me energy.
It just makes me sleepy.
Well,
it does,
but It also robs you of resources.
It's really not a good idea to eat a lot
of food before you go to bed because a
lot of times you bought body starts
digesting that food
and it uses up resources which you
should go to bed.
You shouldn't be hungry,
but there should be some time between
when you eat and when you go to bed,
allow your body to them food so that
your body can adequately go into the
many stages that it requires to really
rebuild your system.
I'm going to feel like I eat now.
I'll fall asleep like I'll be like.
I know,
but I'm just saying like it's not the
smartest thing to do.
Gets sleepy after they eat a lot,
but it's really not the right the right
thing to do.
the right thing to do,
especially if you eat anything heavy
carbs,
bro.
Science coming up,
strap strap in for brown science,
allegedly the spike in insulin that you
get from taking in all those.
If you like pizza,
you have like a whole pizza to yourself.
It's like you're late night life anD
we're all laughing and stoned and we all
ordered five pizzas.
That's not good.
Good.
I like it.
Might be good for those 20 minutes while
you're eating that pizza.
I'm saying if I have soup,
if I just have some like chicken soup.
Lying,
wendy's double double.
I love soup.
I do to say soup soup is one of my
favorite blues blueprint number,
bro.
My.
It's great because my girlfriend is like
a huge cooker and so I just have to tell
her what I call the chef.
Yeah,
but she can say cooker,
cook or something.
You throw food in.
She's a crock pot,
but she's like,
I got this white bean soup that my mom
used to make.
It was like a midwest trash type thing
where it's like,
you know the one with the white beans
and it's a little thicker.
Like a chilean has like bacon or ham in
it and it's so good.
My mom sent me her recipe and she cooked
a bunch of it,
but I eat almost the whole thing of
soup.
Yeah.
My mom used to make split pea soup with
ham.
God damn.
That was good.
Split split.
Split pea soup is not bad for you unless
you're a pig that's really bad for you.
Either you're on the menu,
they're like split pea,
it sounds like.
Oh,
what a wonderful dish.
It's organic.
It's vegetable based.
Not so much
bitch.
There's actually a smoked out dead pig
inside of that thing in the.
You have to have the bone.
If you do it correctly.
He supposed to cook it with the ham hock
on the internet.
This piece of bacon with a nipple still
attached to it.
It's not real.
It is real.
It is 100 percent real boiled pork
belly.
So.
Well,
that's what baking in.
let me explain to you what bacon
is because if you don't know because I
didn't know until a couple of years ago.
Oh,
bacon.
Is this part of the pig?
The bottom half a pig.
This is one of the reasons whY bacon
doesn't really exist on wild boars.
Like,
uh,
I've only shot one wild pig and they
don't have any bacon.
MaN.
They're out there hustling.
They're a different animal.
It's,
it doesn't look the same either.
I mean,
I shot a pretty big one.
It was pretty well fed,
but their
uh,
their,
their skin,
their flesh is not pink or white,
like a,
you know,
it was always pork.
The other white meat,
it's not supposed to be white because
they're out there eating egg corns and
ground nesting birds and all the stuff
that like,
they're,
they're not herbivores either.
Those things are omnivores.
TheY eat,
they eat fucking everything district.
There's this picture that I tweeted a
few months back of a boar running away
with a font in its mouth,
like a small deer and its mouth and a
lot of people were like,
whoa.
I did not know.
They eat babies,
they'll eat a deer,
they fucking eat your cat.
They'll eat your dog deli everything.
They'll you to you fuck an.
Apparently every year someone falls into
a pen with pigs on a farm and gets
jacked.
Look at this pig running off with his
deer and it's mal.
How yo,
that's dark.
Do you see that?
Speaking of pigs in derek,
did you see that cop shooting the deer
video?
Yeah,
that's fucked up man.
I did a shot right in the head is so
stupid.
It's so stupid.
And he,
you know,
it was really callous.
Yeah,
that was brutal.
Well,
I think,
yeah,
it was really callous,
man.
It was weird.
I guess he had to do it though.
I think that's what they said.
They said,
do you have to shoot it?
I think he asked someone what to do and
I think they said put it down.
So I mean,
if you're going to put it Down the way
he did it,
even though it looked crazy because he
did it in front of everybody with the
way he did,
it was the best way to do it,
honestly.
Shoeing.
HeRe's the thing.
I mean,
I don't know what they're going to do
with the body.
I would hope,
hope they give that meet to hunters for
the hungry.
There is a program that's an America
where hunters like say if you,
uh,
you come over here to experience like
the midwest of the United States,
like Iowa in particular,
um,
Kansas.
A lot of these areas are famous all
across the world for having these
gigantic white tail deer and it becomes
a thing like white tail deer in the
midwest of the United States.
This is something I've only found out
over the last few years,
obviously of me getting interested in
hunting,
but white tail deer hunting,
like people hear about it from scotland
and they want to come over here.
People hear about it from China.
They want to come over here.
They want to experience what it's like
to to hunt white tail deer in Iowa.
It becomes like this thing and sometimes
people from other places that don't live
in Iowa will,
they'll,
they'll put in tags and they'll put in
tags over and over and over and over and
over and over and over and finally they
get one and they can go there and they
can experience what it's like and then
they can't bring the meat back to China
or Australia.
They can't,
they won't let you.
Like if you try to fly with a dead deer
from the United States and flying into
Australia,
they'd be like,
fuck you.
Fuck you,
you can't take a chance and going across
the fucking ocean,
it's really funny because if you go from
Nevada to like Ohio,
they're like,
okay,
what do you got in there?
Oh,
I shot A deer.
Congratulations.
but he can't fly across water.
We're going to cross water.
It's very tricky.
Even if you try to bring an animal down
from Canada into the United States.
Well,
I mean I'm talking about a dead animal,
you know,
you're trying to bring a dead animal.
It's um,
sO it's,
it's one of those things Where it,
uh,
like these people donate money or do
they donate food?
So if they come over here and they want
experience,
if they're a hunter from Australia,
they want to experience what it's like
to hunt in Iowa.
They can donate money or In the sense of
they can donate food rather to a,
like a lot of hungry people.
Like if you shoot a 200 pound white tail
deer that's gonna feed,
that's going to be more than probably in
the neighborhood of 150 meals.
That's amazing.
You can,
you can give that away to all these
people that need it.
You know,
if you're from some other place.
This particular.
I thought I recognize this when I saw
the video.
Apparently this video is from 2013.
This is like two and a half years old.
This is not a new thing.
It just happened to be.
We don't care if it's three years old.
This is old shit.
This is the one that's going around from
yesterday.
I saw it says also that the deer was
believed to be injured and what's going
to pretend a harm motorist if they try
to shoo it away,
which is why they hit by a car.
It could have been hit by a car
also.
Just could be on the way out.
Yeah,
I mean that was a pretty big deer.
It could be on the way out.
It could have been shot by an arrow or a
bullet.
You know?
Somebody could have wounded it.
Do you see the deer and the bear video?
What are you doing?
Jamie?
Quake champions.
What are you trying to do?
Oh,
jamie tried to use subliminal messages
on with jamie.
Tried to do just now what they used to
do in the old days with the movies.
Hungry.
Eat popcorn.
Running.
Chasing this.
Yes.
Quake champions debut gameplay trailer.
Okay,
let me wipe my hands.
Dry.
Breathe.
Oh my god.
Look at the graphics shit.
Oh,
so awesome.
Holy shit.
Wow.
Pure,
pure,
pure.
That's
to be a super dork.
To know what fds is.
Frames
for a second.
That was an old hold
rocket arena map did.
They were just playing on.
That's what a dork I am.
I know that map.
The last map.
That was an old map that we used to
always play on.
I don't remember the map number.
There was an old map.
They definitely kept the fueled and the
look of the game by updated the
graphics.
I really liked how they stayed true to
the original formula.
I hope they make it so you can't shut
those graphics off.
This is why.
And people get mad at me.
Fuck bro.
Motherfucking computer doesn't have good
firms.
The problem is you're not playing the
same game as a person who's seen
everything,
like it's easier to play.
well,
I take that back.
I support your decision to mute all the
graphics,
but I think he kinda missing part of the
fun.
Like when you play,
maybe not.
Maybe I'm full of shit.
Here's why I'm full of shit.
Here's why I'm definitely full of shit.
I don't give a fuck about those.
Walgett looks cool the first time you
see it.
Right?
But what do you really want to do?
You want to shoot that fucking dude,
that's what I want to do.
If I shoot him in a perfectly muted
environment where he's the only thing
that I can aim at and everything else is
like mav.
No,
no,
no tan.
Like what's that?
What's a white people tan?
Would that be if you had a crayon like
people 10 trump or trump's not white.
It's like an orange garfield and people
would get super mad if you're asking for
a snow cone with nothing in it and they
gave him something to color of trump.
Like old man,
his shadow leather color shed a leather
head today.
Shimmy definitely hit his head today.
Times spin on tmz.
Too long.
Did it jokes folks?
No,
no bullying.
Relax.
Everybody relax.
Don't do.
Um,
what if you have a computer though?
That's so powerful that it doesn't
matter if you have the graphics on our
night and like the textures.
Fuck that textures,
you can do it.
No,
it doesn't change anything.
Yeah.
But here's the thing.
It's not,
but it's not about that.
It used to be about some people used to
like to run it.
There's two things going on.
One,
some people like to run it with the
graphics muted because they're video
card can handle the frames per second.
The required to run it at like high
resolution with high frame rates.
The higher frame rates make things more
smooth.
So if you get,
they say the human eye can only see 30
frame rates a second.
They need to update that.
I know for a fact they need to update
that because there's,
or at least maybe it doesn't apply,
I should say,
to video games because there's something
that happens in video games when it goes
from 30 frames per second to 120 frames
per second,
plus it becomes far smoother and when
it's smoother,
there's less calculation as far as where
that person is at any given time because
though your mind
can't really say,
oh,
I see where there's a bunch of frames
that are rolling by and that's giving me
this illusion of movement and it's all
being calculated by a cpu.
Your brain doesn't really totally get
that,
but there's some amount of data that's
getting through when something.
It's kind of clunky.
There's some amount of data that's
getting through that,
oh,
this is not.
I just gotta figure out where that
thing's going to be,
but this,
that thing is,
it's all like hickey.
It's a hiccupy thing.
When it gets to 120 frames per second,
it's smooth as butter.
Then it starts looking like,
okay,
this is a cartoon.
Now I'm watching a cartoon,
a cartoon,
and smooth,
right?
A cartoon doesn't have anything to herky
jerky stuff to it,
and this is like a super smooth cartoon
like some of the video games you play
like unreal tournament.
Remember unreal Tournament,
you get into high resolutions and each
the screams the players and she the
fucking laser beams shooting chunk,
chunk,
chunk.
It's crazy,
right?
It's crazy.
And high frames per second.
It's very smooth.
It's really fun and interesting to
watch.
and when that happens your mind doesn't
have to calculate as much because it,
it's more predictable.
it's like,
it's smoother,
it's more,
uh,
it's more pleasing to the eyes,
but you're still dealing with all those
textures so that you're calculating
whether you like it or not or even know
it or not.
Every Time you pass by some gothic stone
wall and there's moss on it,
it's amazing looking.
your mind either has to deny the
existence of that or it has to calculate
that into what it's modeled.
The world is.
So that's extra.
It's extra processing power.
It's unnecessary.
So if the walls were all like the best
players,
what they would do is they would turn
all the textures off so they would only
have this like weird,
like a tron world,
like with tron tron blew a fuse blew and
you're in this strange virtual
environment or all the walls are flat
and matte white.
You.
Yeah,
it's,
it's something that I used to have to do
just to play in that game on my own.
Yeah,
my old computer.
But I think nowadays though,
I think for the most part,
like a game like this should probably
run pretty perfectly on almost any
computer game right here.
Has the shadows on.
But it has the textures off fine one
that has the shadows off too because
that happens to some crazy fuckers and
what might not be in quake three,
which I think that a quick live.
But I'm in the older games guys had
gotten it down to almost nothing.
There was no shadow,
there was no nothing.
Everything was like this weird
artificial environment.
If you just started a textures off,
just like quick to react,
quick to um,
shadows off and textures often quick to
it might be a hack really.
It might not even necessarily be
something that I'm now that was in the
original settings.
I remember it.
Was it.
Yeah,
because it's all based on your graphics
card.
A lot of graphics cards couldn't handle
shadows
and stuff like that.
Yeah.
But also in competition dudes figured
out pretty early on that it'd be easier
to hit people.
There were the only things that you were
looking at?
Yeah,
if I had to play like competitively,
I definitely shut everything off.
Yeah.
Because it'll make you better cheating's
just like cutting weight.
It's like cutting weight for video
games.
Did you used to play the old unreal
maps?
Like the one in the bathroom?
We were sitting on top of the paper
roll.
I played that one.
That was unreal.
It was cool.
It was like fans of quake made an
awesome game.
That's what it was like,
you know,
and plug.
It was cool because didn't we get to see
unreal tournament before it even came
out?
Yeah.
We went to the studio.
I think it was unreal.
It was unreal.
It was one of the unreal,
eh.
One of the unreal releases.
I'm trying to remember which one it was
the first time we met cliff.
Cliff is so normal.
He's great.
I love cliff and he's.
He wouldn't think he'd be like some
super genius like video game creator.
He seems like such a normal dude.
Yeah,
totally.
Do you know his game by the way,
if one of his games just hit itunes
called shadow complex,
it's one of my favorite games,
but now you can a phone,
you name it.
It's a computer game you get on mac and
I think you could do it on the phone
too.
I just saw it the other day.
I'm not sure.
What is it?
It's a like a side scroller like old
school kind of like where where you're
figuring out like puzzles and playing
like shooting game.
there's a game that's out that I just
finished the other day.
It's one of the best video games I've
here.
LIfe.
That shadow complex remastered.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's this,
this cliff.
He's new game.
That's one of his games that came out a
couple of years ago when after he left,
uh,
I believe,
he left epic.
dude,
I'm so lucky I'm not a teenager today.
I'll get this.
Bullets are going under water.
I would never get anything done.
I would get fucking nothing done.
I would have never gotten involved in
martial arts.
Maybe I would've,
but I might not have.
I might've just done this.
God damn.
I might've had more fun.
Might've been good at twitch then maybe.
It just seems so fucking compelling.
When you watch these video games today,
they're so goddamn compelling.
There's this new game that I just
finished that you can get for like 20
bucks right now inside.
Right.
But it's one of the best experiences of
video game I've ever had in my life was
the graphics.
It's,
it's like a puzzle kind of games and
game where you try to fIgure shit out.
But the ending and the fuel of the games
is,
it's,
it's the field of game is some of the,
probably the one of the best video games
I've ever experienced in my life.
And it's really hard.
Like there's words brian read.
There's super cool.
I just played it too.
Oh yeah.
wow.
Whoa,
whoa.
And it doesn't tell you how to play.
There's no real.
It's just moving and jumping.
Really.
You don't really need to.
There's no real strange controls.
But should we sell nothing off the for
anything?
And that's when the game.
It's not that long to play.
You can get through in a couple of hours
if you're figuring it out,
but it'll take you longer if you get
stuck.
The ending is one of the most beautiful
pieces are our masterpieces of video
game I've ever seen in my life.
Wow.
Beautiful.
Creepy.
Yeah.
This is cool to watch.
Yeah,
it's really fun with shadows.
My god.
And this isn't even that crazy of
graphics.
It's,
it's just,
it's done,
right,
dude.
It's good feeling.
Duncan trussell has the oculus rift and
he also has the vive.
The htc vive and he showed me this
archery game the other day and the htc
vive and I don't think I can have this
in my house.
Yeah,
you can.
No,
no,
I don't think I can have in the studio
here.
I don't think I could have it anywhere.
I would have.
I would have a real problem.
I played that fucking archery game until
my arms were shaking.
You're on the top of a castle and these
things are like charging at nacho and
shooting at them from the top of the
castle.
IT's super addictive.
Yeah.
Did you have a game called quiver?
I just pulled this up when I was looking
for archery and divide.
This looks like he's got a gang of
games,
but this isn't the one that I played or
at least it's not the scene that I
played a lot of games,
but not good games.
Like this is like,
like the graphics.
This looks like a nintendo 64.
The graphics are not the best,
but seriously man,
you're not going to give a fuck when you
were in those goddamn htc vive.
Go goggles is the coolest shit in the
world.
You should get together with dunkin,
go to his house,
do his a podcast,
and,
and play the vive.
Before you do it,
you're going to be blown away.
I have the,
uh,
the,
the cheap $30 one that you can buy where
you put your samsung phone in and they
don't do that.
This is the one I played.
Yeah,
these motherfuckers just vr archery.
You got to shoot at these,
um,
these balloons.
It's fucking real accurate.
That's what's crazy.
Like you just got to get a feel of which
way it's going and how fast it's going.
See,
like it has a certain amount of frames
per second,
um,
uh,
feet per second rather.
So the arrow,
you have to kind of lead them,
like if you know they're jumping,
you have to figure out where they're
going to be.
When the arrows get in there,
you know,
if they're real close,
it's easy,
like right there,
bam.
It's easy.
He's right there.
But if they're moving,
they're moving left to right.
You kind of get a judgment.
See how this guy is doing that.
He's figuring it out.
He's leading them.
They're moving.
Bam.
They're running right into the arrows.
That's great.
That's what I figured out how to do
after awhile and that gets super
addictive because it's really rewarding
because first of all,
you don't feel guilty at all because
they're not even people.
They're just total cartoons.
Silhouettes With vikki helmets on and
shields,
so you don't feel bad.
What happened here?
Is that the same thing?
Is that what happened to the later?
Later?
yeah.
They give you a gun.
Hilarious.
They're like,
you're so good.
You realize that it's stupid to have a
bow and arrow here.
We'll give you a laser.
Oh,
they give you a laser radar later.
Later,
later,
later.
The olympics.
Right now we're in this for samsung
devices.
They're in it.
Yeah.
You could watch the in vr,
like look around.
Oh wow.
Did you change or did you try it?
The porn though,
the no,
I did not.
Porn is what was going to choose
to.
Duncan was too insistent that I do it
and I got nervous.
I got the fuck out of there.
I was Like,
you got to relax son.
Yeah,
make me nervous.
You don't want to have a gaga
dude.
I'm telling you.
You got to watch the porn man.
I'll sit over here.
You won't even see me.
He wanted to look at your lips when you
were watching it.
Girl.
He probably snapchat the whole thing
while you.
You're playing anyways.
Did the porn.
The porn though really is something that
changes everything.
Like watching porn and that really like
you take it off and you're like,
oh no,
I felt closer to the girl than I thought
I would.
That's,
that's going to save porn if,
if this does catch on.
Well maybe because it'll make it too.
If they can monetize the htc and the
oculus to the point where they can lock
down the format.
Like the way they have the iphone locked
down.
Like you can't add anything to the app
store unless apple gives you approval if
they can control it and that sort of
same way.
I'm not saying tHat's the best thing for
everybody because I kinda liked the idea
of open source things.
One of the,
I use a mac and I use it for convenience
and because I'm too busy I got have time
to fuck with some window shit,
but part of me likes the fact that
windows is open and I've heard that
argument before,
like I've had conversations with people
before with like,
look,
anybody could write shit for windows.
You know,
it's like you can make products that
work on windows,
you can make your own laptops,
you can put together your own desktops.
Like it's,
it's a much more open sort of a platform
than mac is because mac is the software
developer and the hardware developer.
The good thing about that is everything
works pretty fucking good.
Like you get a laptop from apple pretty
fucking sure it's gonna work,
awesome,
etc.
And died.
What happened?
Oh just stop working.
But we've had every Fucking computer
dies.
Windows even,
right?
They all die.
What's my point?
My point is a point.
If I had a point,
it would be that I'm taking it and
monetizing the applications that you
would use for the htc vive or oculus
only makes sense.
I thiNk what we're going to see though
is,
especially when the xbox and the
playstation released their vr ca
counterpoints,
I think that's when it's really going to
become an everyday thing and I think
it's going to hurt the,
the these kinds oF guys like the htcs
and the oculus people a lot because I
think it's going to be like computer
games and then,
oh hey,
this is an x box.
You know,
that kind of killed pc gaming a lot and
a lot of a lot of ways.
I think there's going to be a lot of
copyright lawsuits for sure because
they're going to have to figure out who.
Who invented the critical aspects for
like truly immersive virtual reality,
like what
critical aspects are there?
Have they identified them?
Who invented those?
Because those are huge.
You know,
if one guy figured out a way to make
this,
the frame rate's incredibly smooth,
so there's no news,
no ability to discern when you moving
left to right,
whether you're moving fast or slow.
If one guy wrote some sort of a program
or figured out something that I would
imagine.
I'm not a lawyer obviously,
but I'd imagine there'd be some sort of
a case for that.
Like all these trolls,
patent trolls that apple gets hit with
all the time.
Like I would imagine that that's going
to be crazy when it comes to this stuff.
Yeah.
Unless It's already been licensed,
licensed it out,
you know,
it could be just some old guy going,
oh,
you'll give me $2,000,000
a year.
You might get brian's idea of commerce
is an episode or a fucking one of the,
uh,
back to the future movies where like a
delorean and need some plutonium.
this guy just happens that I think
though,
I think,
I think next year is when xbox is
releasing.
There's,
I think playstation's coming out this
year maybe.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Well,
I don't think you can patent virtual
reality.
I mean,
lawnmower man was low as 1992.
What year was lawnmower man?
fInd that?
Let's guess.
I would guess 1994.
Ninety four.
Ninety five.
I say nine.
Two,
nine,
two,
one.
Oh,
by the way,
complete total guests.
I had no idea it was right.
Okay.
But total recall is also a virtual
reality movie.
We watched the running man.
Oh,
that's terrible.
Horrible.
That did not have your childhood.
I'm telling you.
people were stupid as fuck back when we
were kids.
We didn't realize how dumb we were until
we watch old movies.
Was it was 1990 for a total recall.
Nineteen 90.
Interesting.
Even earlier.
Um,
so those are those.
Those are vIrtual reality movies.
So it's not like virtual reality is like
some thing that someone invented.
It's really like a hope and a dream.
It's no waste to send a desert.
It's like everybody who lives a shitbag
life is hoping there's gotta be some way
that I can be superman told her recall
wasn't technically a virtual reality is
false memories being implanted in your
brain strain.
That's why he's being danger days.
That's true,
but it's kind of that reality is kind of
virtual.
It's creating an artificial memory.
no,
you're totally right.
it was an artificial memory movie.
Yeah.
Strange days was a virtual reality
movie,
but there's been a few others.
RIght.
There's been a few others.
But um,
what do you think with the.
Was the big one?
What's the biggest one?
Virtual reality movie matrix.
The matrix.
Yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
Right?
I don't even think of that.
Yeah,
that's the biggest.
So like,
I don't think anybody come along and say
they invented virtual reality,
like that's sort of like a whole.
It's like a horn blowing in the distance
that we all knew it was coming and it's
not even like if even if you look at
video games,
you can say video games are virtual
reality.
Just very bad versIons of him,
you know,
like,
like super mario brothers.
That's a virtual reality of a plumber.
What is this virtual reality is coming
to your movie theater near you ends.
I've heard a lot of people talk about
this as a pretty cool movie.
I don't think I've ever seen or heard of
1999.
I think jude law's in it.
That's a name of a boner pill.
Jennifer.
Jason leigh.
Mmm.
I don't know.
I can't speak on it,
but I've heard a lot of people said that
it was like an under the radar kind of
good movie came out in 1999,
which is the same year.
the matrix came out probably.
Why no one heard about it.
Huh?
It's supposed to be a good mom is a
three and a half stars is that three and
a quarter stars for three and a half to
eight.
A 71 fucking rotten tomatoes star
search.
We covered in empire of allies.
[inaudible]
maybe.
Maybe the corporation realizes the
benefit isn't telling the truth.
THe way to make the money is not to
create bad reviews are fake reviews.
The money is in being brutally honest
and reaping the rewards of people coming
to read these really country review.
That's why I get my news and information
from only hashtags nowadays.
Oh,
that's good marriage.
You do that like every time there's any
helicopter in burbank.
I'm like hashtag burbank and like,
what's going on?
This is what I do every morning when I
wake up,
I go hashtag apocalypse.
See what's the most recent post I'm
going to go back to sleep.
I go outside and shoot my rubber elk.
It's more Fast.
Inaccurate though.
It's usually one guy going dude or the
helicopter down on the street.
Well,
there's definitely some shit
going down in these.
Like if you follow like social media
news feeds,
like people that are on the scene,
they're talking about some cops shooting
some kid or something like that.
I mean that's one of the best ways to
get some data.
The question is the veracity of the
data,
like whether or not it's god damn,
I sound like a professor.
I need to apply for a job somewhere.
Teaching the voracity of the data must
come into question the biases of the
person.
Did you go to their twitter page?
What are they into?
How many noam chomsky books of the road?
Are you sure they're right?
Right?
You never know,
but you could find out some shit's going
down.
There's like a.
There was a video of the dallas shootout
between the guy and the cops,
those,
uh,
the former military guy who killed all
those fucking cops.
Hmm.
Whew.
That's a tough video to watch,
man.
There's this one scene.
I think it was him that did it or
someone else who shot someone else.
I don't know how.
Here's all I saw a person was running
down the street and a person in this,
this,
these two people involved in a gunfight
and one guy shot behind the guy and hit
the wall behind them and then use that
as a distraction to run in front of him
and shoot him when he's laying down.
I was like,
wow,
I was.
That guy has done
this before games.
I hate this.
I hate to say that.
It really is video guys.
Well,
in this case,
if it's the same guy who killed all
those people,
it's a guy who was in war in the first
place.
So we'd actually play the ultimate video
game.
He's playing actual war,
but these school shootings and stuff,
man,
do you remember that call of duty when
you walk into the airport?
You just mow down people like you just
pretty much go into lax with a machine
gun.
Just start spraying everybody.
That alone.
I remember you playing a going.
I'm.
I can't believe my eyes and brain are
seeing this right now and I've played so
many video games before that I've gone
outside and forgot that I'm not in that
video game still.
This is crazy.
So they gunned down all the people.
Oh shit.
And you're just walking through the
airport doing this.
You're finding people hiding and stores
and shit.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
This is so your brand.
So you saw that trump support or suction
cup.
Michael swimmer guy.
See I'm all in favor of video games and
I have a problem with quake like
violence,
but this is fucked up because this is
murder.
You're just running around and
assassinating average moms and dads and
brothers and sisters like this is a
video game where you're deriving
pleasure from gunning people down.
Like why would you.
And this is available to buy at target
is.
It is.
Yeah.
This is call of duty like last few years
ago,
and look at this guy's walking through
the fucking starbucks.
Yeah,
the bookstore.
A choice he's making just gunned down.
Don't have to do this.
And again,
still definitely shoot for you instead
basically.
But so you can just decide to be a
killer and it guess what you're going to
do joe,
you are actually going to not,
you're going to actually shoot people
because I've played this and I'm like
this is horrible.
Why am I doing?
And I was like,
even like people hiding in the back,
please note and be like,
I'll talk to them.
I'm like,
yeah,
you're hiding boy.
And then he shoot them.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
It's like grand theft auto.
I through the same shit man.
Like why am I doing this?
Like I engraved theft auto.
It's a lot more fucked up.
I mean,
you know,
it started with the hooker.
Give me a blow job and then killing her.
You know,
a couple of grand theft auto first came
out.
Do you have to kill her?
No.
You should just give her money.
Let her go about her way and saw,
oh,
I killed my every time.
Get my money back and you killed a
hooker.
You get your money back and if she has
any extra money.
Oh my god,
dude,
that's so crazy.
But like,
like in grand theft auto,
I don't even play the missions.
I'll just go to the gun store,
get as much as I possibly possibly can
and I have like this one part Where
height on this second floor of this
house and I pretty much or the comedy
store hanging out at the comedy store
and I pretty much just put it down
grenades and bombs and blow up until
there are so many cars.
It's just a pile of meat on sunset
boulevard and it's great fun.
yeah,
it is fucked up that you can be a
monster and with no consequences.
I guess in my head I jusT have to say
they're all rapists or something,
but here's the.
But here's the problem.
Like at what point in time is this going
to become way more disturbing because
it's going to be virtual,
not virtual yet.
It's just you're looking at a screen and
have you seen the virtual version of
this yet?
That they are very aware that it's not
real.
Right.
Like at what point in time are you going
to be not aware that it's not real?
You gotta throw a grenade at this guy.
Really?
I tell you,
jane anthro?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I strap like sticky bombs onto people.
But uh,
it's gotten to the point where I used to
play games.
Not this game,
but city of heroes is like torkey game.
But I played it straight for a month,
like every single hour of the day.
A long time ago.
He chose a broken bottle.
Yeah.
Oh,
jesus christ.
You should see what I did in the strip
club.
I catch it on fire and I just burned
strippers.
Man.
I put my bike in the front door so they
can't escape.
It's great.
This is crazy,
man.
Oh my god.
He just stabbed like this is so fucked
up.
He stabbing him in the ass of the broken
bottle.
Oh,
jesus christ.
Look at this,
right?
It's butthole.
Look is buttholes bleeding.
This is so fucked up.
You know what,
man?
Tipper gore was right,
she saw the future,
she was trying to stop rap lyrics and
this is ultimately what was down the
road and how girls wife,
a lot of people don't remember that.
Al gore's wife in the 19 eighties went
on a crusade against violent music and a
violent lyrics and rap and she was uh,
she was hated.
It was really interesting and she just
shut the fuck up when he was running for
president with the chickens.
Two live crew.
Yeah,
she was.
She was against a bunch of them.
I think it was.
Ice tea had an issue with her.
Let's get naked and fuck tonight.
That was one of jams.
That was a joint,
a nice ice t joint fused.
Uh,
I think purple rain,
which is what she used to lead that
ended up with the rental advisory.
Use that as an example.
It migHt have been that or something
else.
I'm reading fifth.
Sorry.
I lost it.
Telling you we're going to take jamie
ride to a doctor now.
Dr.
You're going to take jamie to that talk
as minute clinic clinics,
working with meg,
your head injuries.
Prince gave us parental guidance.
What if we find that out?
You're allergic to me.
You have like some black mold in your
asshole or something.
You're just allergic to my smell.
Yo.
Dude.
I was.
Here's some,
some crazy shit.
Um,
did you know that like if someone's
allergic to horses they can't even ride
in a carriage behind a horse.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And I was thinking of this,
you know,
women,
some women
are literally allergic to their man's
come,
like the guy shoots loads on them.
They get rashes all over their body.
Like what?
Like,
like literally some demonic shit,
man,
like a guy shoots a load on you and like
carved his name,
takes his load and writes it with his
finger and just leaves you there to dry
and you have the mark of the demon and
stomach.
Is that because of food allergies that
maybe that's inside the come?
Maybe.
Maybe he or she is allergic to peanuts
and he just eats nonstop peanuts and she
does a very good question.
It's probably something like that could
be.
I'm wondering what it meant.
I wonder if there's a reason jamie,
research that find out what makes come
allergenic and uh,
feel free to deduct any research from
your taxes.
I know like some,
some girls do that ph balance just,
it's totally different from you or
whatever.
And they break out or to of this is
saying she was dosed with diagnosed with
human seminal plasma hypersensitivity
and allergy to seaman.
The problem with guessing that is we
don't know how many different people
came on her and within it wasn't not at
all had the same effect.
And what's the pe ratio to do a double
blind placebo controlled gang.
Not gang bang,
but like,
um,
what would it be?
A bunch of users jerked off on a girl
circle jerk.
there's a little peon come right circle
jerk involves a cracker though.
No,
Like an official sort of sloppy biscuit.
Loves that shit.
I always thought that a circle jerk
involved.
Just a bunch of dudes jerking off
together,
which was weird enough.
then I heard that like the last guy to
come just to eat the cracker.
What kind of a fucking world are we
inventing?
Why do you think bert so fat from all
those crackers come?
No,
it's he's fat from all the booze to get
the com cracker that come.
Cracker.
I mean,
unless there's a billion calories in it
as long time ago.
Her tom's been working out with chicken.
A lot of water.
He's your helPer is fat.
You're on team.
Bird is fat.
Whereas versus team thompson against my
own mom.
Thompson water champ.
Yeah.
tom is the water champ.
Chris.
Christina never drinks water.
They don't drink water.
Do you know they take a shower together
all the time and tom piece on her and
like what would she Be saying this on
the internet?
Five guys.
Well,
I would do that too if I was married.
Or did you ever told a crazy story I'd
never heard joey diaz told about on
there.
Maybe it was on their show that about
him.
Shit in the shower and just push it
through,
throw it,
throw it in the toilet,
and that I believe that shit on his on a
couple of years ago to stop because he
got caught by his wife.
He got caught.
Two ideas.
Is this traits average blue belt?
He's a savage.
Yeah.
He got his blue belt in jujitsu.
Fucking shit.
Emit blue belt in brazilian jujitsu.
He's doing brazilian
jujitsu for I believe four or five years
now and joe has been like really into
it.
It's helped them.
I don't want to get that wrong,
so if I got that number wrong,
but if I guessed it,
I think it would be four or five years,
but he really loves it.
He loves it for fitness,
for,
for health.
You know?
HE's super humble about it,
but if he does it all the time,
I bet you every single person who goes
against tax out he's going to have is
blacked out in like two months.
It's like the smell,
the smell.
What are you saying?
SMells now.
Think about these things before you say,
I remember climbing up the stairs.
You'll see margins pc,
this joke about you want to see you walk
by me when I'm farting up a flight of
stairs.
You'll see.
You'll see marsh has no tolerance for
nonsense.
It's like if eddie bravo starts talking
about eddie ufo or anything like crazy
crypto fucking duology type shit or
whatever eddie's into recently,
jelly will fucking get up and leave the
room.
BuT joe rogan,
I don't want to listen to your fucking
you up.
We'll talk.
Okay.
I know.
Yeah.
That show with duncan.
You went looking for bigfoot.
Leave them in the fucking forest.
Okay.
Gentlemen.
He used to call tim duncan and satanic,
but satan worshiper.
She fucking member when anton levay or
stand,
whichever one it was,
the young guy got married and duncan
performed at his wedding and sick and he
invited a bunch of us to go to his
wedding.
So we went to his wedding and,
and,
and duncan was involved with this like
satanic,
fake,
satanic wedding day foley's ex wife was
there too.
And a satanic duncan.
Yeah,
because he had this routine that he
should do.
I don't know if he still does it.
He was on his phone.
What does he say?
Give me some volume.
You play this full screen to joey
duncan.
Duncan trussell.
We've got to have a little talk you.
When I sit on.
What's this?
What's this fucking devil shit.
I'm hearing.
Everybody's telling me you have a
worshiper.
Duncan duncan.
We can't have that.
Can't have that.
You understand that you're a comedIan.
No more of this devil.
Shit.
You scared.
I'm good.
I got it from four different people.
Not even people I got from one of joe's
friends,
but everybody else at the store is
saying the devil.
You're walking around with a fucking
crucifix on your head and shit that you
put a little fucking tattoo on you and
your score was six,
six,
six that you're calling yourself duncan.
This duncan.
We can't have this no more.
You understand me?
If we have to kill a little homo will
kill him.
No,
we can't have.
Legit.
You're a catholic.
Were you raised catholic?
But were you raised?
All right.
That'll be fucking no more of this
double shit.
We can't have this.
You scaring people.
These people are white people and just
of them bro.
They want to call the authorities and
shit.
You know what I'm saying?
His eyes caught by her dog.
What's his name by the store?
The guy who does the app show wants to
call the cops.
This is that the atlanta punchline.
The old bro.
He's got four people called the house
and left messages.
They're worried about duncan trussell.
This shit has to happen.
Don't get in the game looking.
They take kids like you,
they but fuck you.
And they picked the same cross up here
and then you know what I'm saying?
You can't come back from that.
You can't recover from that.
I'm not fucking laughing here.
Yeah,
I have.
Okay.
And I remember going when at that time
of that period of time,
like me and duncan,
I would always go to his friend's house,
that guy and you'd get these houses.
It was like people that believed in st.
Maybe not seriously or anything,
but I remember going,
wow,
dunkin is.
It's some deep shit to.
Dunkin was always,
I think a joke,
but it was.
We were hanging out with really intense
tense people,
you know,
like.
Yeah,
super intense.
yeah.
Well duncan's into intense humans and
intense ideas and for awhile he was
really attracted to this idea not of
satanism in that satan is an actual
being in the devil is real and that
you're praying to the devil,
but satanism in that these people were
like essentially hedonist.
They were just like seeking pleasure and
trying to have as much fun as they
could,
but they were also allowing other people
to do it too.
So you like redefining what satanism is
and like,
well,
if that's okay,
that's the problem with all ideologies
like you're locked into,
if you want to call it satanism and it's
all,
hey man,
just be free.
Just have a good time and you know,
just fucking do whatever feels good.
Terrible.
Don't get it.
But there's a big difference between
that in and of itself,
which is an awesome idea,
right?
Like everybody agrees like you should.
Yeah.
Have fun,
man.
We're only here for a little bit at a
time.
If you get your toes sucked,
fucking get your toe socks.
Who cares,
right,
but there is a big fucking difference
between that and something that's
connected to a demon.
It's connected to a fallen angel who
became a devil,
who lives in us,
a smoldering inferno in the middle of
the earth,
and if he gets a hold of you and you
don't listen to god,
you will burn to the end of the time.
What?
What are you retarded?
Why does it have to be connected to
that?
Why is that good feeling and having a
good time and pleasure and
being a whole bag if that's what you're
into.
If you're a girl you like,
we're in dental,
floss up your ass and going out to bars
and sucking three dicks.
Who cares?
Right?
Why does it
have to be connected to the devil?
Because that's a sin.
All those are synced to enough.
Brian red band.
I forsake v enough.
Enough with these fuckers.
One last little thing I want to show
you.
I have you seen this new game maybe or
may not have.
It's called no man's sky.
Whoops.
What's really interesting about it is,
as far as I understand,
I'm been trying to figure it out,
the uh,
there's,
it's an unexplored space and if there's
something like 10 billion planets that
are being populated in this multiplayer
universe,
and as a player,
what you're supposed to do is go and
explore and find species and planets.
Hold on.
Can you say 10 billion planets in the
first 24 hours or two days?
This was up.
They've already named more species in
this game than there are on earth.
It.
See?
It's all computer generated.
So when you play the game,
it automatically generates a planet.
So it's just random random shit.
Yeah,
I get that.
But what the fuck?
Say that again?
It's more species in this game and how
many days,
and I'll look up that article that says
more than more speed,
but you know,
the reviews of this game is pretty
boring.
Oh my god.
It's just a,
it's a little slower of a game.
It's not like a first person shooter.
It's not that typical kind of game,
but it's supposedly a truly open
universe.
And the game just came out this week.
A lot of people have been really
anticipating it for like the last couple
months.
So is this game,
it says truly open universe.
So is this game constantly inventing
itself on the fly?
Oh my god.
Sort of like real dude.
Do you have any idea what it's going to
be like when that's on the htc vive and
we're not in 2016,
but when they're in 2000,
67,
we were living in another world man.
For instance,
in one night we hit 10 million species
discovered in mms.
That's more than has been discovered on
earth.
What is going on?
It is a testament to how amazing our
network coders are.
That discoveries are still working at
all.
Wow.
This is yesterday.
We're already in a simulation,
joe.
It is for them.
You know,
it's like that's a simulation.
I mean it's not the best one,
but it's like taking a motorola startac.
IF someone says,
do you have a cell phone?
And you're like,
yes I do.
And you pull out a motorola startac like
that's on a fucking cell phone.
But it is,
it's just not a good one.
Like are we already in the simulation?
Yeah.
It's already happened.
It's just not good yet.
You kind of know it's there,
but it's,
it's definitely a simulation and it's
getting way weirder.
It's getting way weirder.
I feel like when I pay attention to the
news and I paid attention to the
internet and I just stepped back and
we'll look at this crazy trump clinton
race and I look at this.
This is bizarre,
strange world that we find ourselves
sorta like waking up in.
I can only imagine how fucking weird
it's going to be in a decade.
I can only imagine.
We should really consider getting water
and shelter and figuring out how to get
solar power.
We can get this kid really fall apart.
That guy in Virginia does that.
They took away as the land.
What guy?
There's this,
I think it was Virginia.
They took away his land because he was
off the grid,
like he did everything off the grid,
so he was not paying any city utility at
all and they didn't like it.
So they just took his land away from
them.
Which guys?
This uh,
if you google image was on the news,
Virginia homeowner fighting to keep
property from being taken away by
eminent domain.
Yeah,
I think that's it.
It's just putting him in that domain is
different than when a company gets from
february.
It's old shit bro.
Just too new.
I'm going to.
Domain is scary because I'm going a
domain is like if they're trying to put
a highway through something,
they can just buy your house.
You have to move a put,
you know,
like you see those houses that are like
on the side of the four,
oh five.
They're doomed.
Doomed.
They're going to spread that bitch.
You can't keep all these fucking people
together.
It's just not working.
There's too many of us.
Unless everybody gets automatic cars,
there's no more accidents.
And even then we're going to realize
what a bottleneck.
Just the sheer volume of humans there
are.
I'm pretty sure that's what's going to
happen.
Like even as China just released their
first neW bus
cars
underneath the bus and I'm going to have
you seen that where it's like it looks
like this and then the in the middle
looks like a,
like you're going through a bridge or a
tunnel.
He so cArs can drive through it in the
top part is the bus part and so things
like that.
Let's say they're at.
I saw that it's like it's like a train
more than a bus,
right?
Because the tracks.
Yeah.
But things like that I think are going
to improve a lot.
I mean imagine if that was just a non
continuous retards going to be playing
pokemon and slam into your fucking
train.
Knock it over on a traffic.
Right?
Yeah.
That's the problem is when you have that
and retain things that are like regular
cars that are driving the same road
together.
If you go under someone,
you're almost like in contact with them.
So if you get an accident while you're
under there,
guys will change lanes while they're
underneath those buses and they'll
collide into each other and they'll
fucking spin the,
the bus out of control to go off the
rails
crashed and other people,
the pulp will die in a horrible crash on
the four.
Oh,
five in los Angeles.
The best pub we've ever had was last at
this ridiculous policy of public
transportation in los angeles has always
been an individual transportation city.
People love their cars.
they love to be by themselves.
I'm looking at this article.
I found out this,
uh,
this might not even be real,
like this thing obviously exists.
It's a real thing.
But the.
See this exact one that showed last week
or whenever this came out was the same
whatever train bus you want to call that
showed in a test that they use six years
before this.
And it was only on like a 300 meter
piece of land and 30.
Even now this says like if this project
is even feasible or if it's even real,
wasn't.
They were just road testing it like
this.
Or I read it as if they're just like,
they're just seeing if this would work.
Like testing,
huh?
Well It makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean it makes sense to have something
like that,
but if people can judge whether or not
they.
Like if something's on sale,
if it's a car,
it's one thing if a guy's hitting the
brakes and turn the wheel and all that
stuff,
it's one thing.
Or if a bus same kind of thing,
but as soon as people interact with
trains,
I have a problem with that because like
one of them is like super steady and
static or move to the same sort of
speeds and it's not.
It doesn't vary.
That was hit the brakes and do a bunch
of things that people have cars do and
the other one does.
So the one that does the one that's real
mobile,
the person driven car is going to figure
out how to time that train.
They got to take some chances if they're
all running through the same road
together and they're cutting each other
off and yeah,
there's gonna be some asshole doesn't
seem like it's to work as good people
are going to tax.
They're going to slam into that thing.
It's just weird.
Can have a train in the car in the same
place.
It seems about as real as hyperloop
maybe is right now.
Which.
Yeah,
well that's sort of real.
At least everything that is real now.
It was a whisper at one time,
so I.
Hyperloop is real in the sense that no
one's written on it yet,
but that is,
that's moving.
There's,
there's movement in that direction.
there's concepts,
there's engineers working,
there's design,
there's all sorts of different people
involved in technology.
They're beIng consulted.
They're trying to figure out how to make
that actually come to light so that it
is a real.
it's just,
it's a.
It's in the embryonic stages.
That fucking thing is going to happen,
man.
We're going to be able to jet across the
whole country and like an hour.
No.
That's going to feel like,
dude,
I'm going to shit my pants.
Shit.
My pants was going to go on a regular
plane goes,
what?
Five hundred miles an hour.
Sure.
Okay,
let's go 200 mIles an hour.
So you get to the other side of the
country in an hour and a half and he
just pinned to your seat.
Try to get up to go to the bathroom.
It's like,
good luck,
dear crosses.
It derails.
Boom.
Flying the deer crosses it.
The front end of it is built like a
sword.
Yeah,
just slices through the deer.
That's what they should have.
They should have like the front of the
thing should be like,
like you know those things that you.
WHen you cut an onion,
you drop it down like slice or like an
egg,
like a hard boiled egg.
You know those things?
Slice slicer.
That's what the front of the train
should be.
It should be razor sharp swords that if
you're so retarded,
do you want to step out or you want to
push your cow in front of the just to
make a youtube video.
It just gets exploded instantaneously.
Just gets sliced through and turned to
mush.
They pretty much have that are already
in the design when it's usually like a v
or illuminati triangle,
you know,
which brings us back to that cop shoot,
that deer,
that deer got eaten by a bunch of hungry
people,
sit nearly as much of a problem that
you're going to say the deers and the
illuminati that that new aluminum,
the deer,
the deer.
What the deere wants to do is stop the
white christian from profile.
That's why dear exist in mostly
primarily white christian towns.
Go to brooklyn.
Find yourself a dear.
Good luck.
Go by canter's deli and la st louis and
find yourself a dear.
Good luck.
Will you find jews.
You do not find deer juice,
but where you find good christian folk
that the jews have made sure that dare
grow takeover and suicide bombing your
automobile of.
You're fine with that.
That's only you but me.
I want to mad max bumper from mad max.
When you go to places like South Dakota,
any of those places where there's a lot
of deer,
I think do.
Would you say Michigan is the worst?
You say?
Michigan.
We went over the country like how many
different people get in car accidents
with deer every year,
and I think Michigan was fucking insane.
Like more than a hundred thousand people
get in car accidents a year with deer.
Well,
to Be honest,
alabama's the worst.
What is that?
What are they at?
One and 127.
One in 100.
20 seven car accidents involve the deer
chance of collision.
It says with,
oh my god,
that's a one percent chance.
Essentially.
That's like if you drive 100 times,
one time we got to kick fucking crazy.
That is if you drive 100 times,
how many times did you have 100 jobs?
Michigan's a little.
Oh,
there's a couple of.
Mississippi is the highest.
Michigan is one in 94.
Wow.
Minnesota times,
but it doesn't matter if there's a deer
in the road.
Why does that,
dan,
rather than fuck it,
bro.
Hippies.
One in 84.
Oh my god.
And montana's one in one 75
Pennsylvania,
one in 71.
And then the top one,
I was in Montana recently,
every fucking person up there has a
battering ram welded to the front of
their truck.
Everyone one in 39.
Oh my god.
Oh my god,
I wasn't.
Sorry,
go ahead.
I was in Michigan like a year ago and we
drove down to do shows in like Michigan
to columbus,
Ohio to whatever.
But the drive from Michigan to columbus,
there was so many dead deer on the side
of the road,
like every half mile there was just dead
bodies and in blood it was just guts and
blood and deer everywhere.
It was really disgusting how many deer
deer there were.
There's a lot.
And there's rules and whether or not you
can eat it like a.
If you get there like right after the
accident,
I think you can call the cops and some
states and they'll let you take the deer
home and eat it.
Which is nice.
I mean if somebody leaves it behind,
look,
if you're a person that's poor and you
run across a deer that just got hit by a
car,
that's like a hundred pounds of meat.
That's like 100 meals,
you know what I mean?
That's amazing for your family,
you know you can all.
So there's a lot of people that get
excited about roadkill,
but the real problem is it kills.
I think he kills 200 people a year in
this country.
Is that the number?
I think it's 200 people a year in this
country alone.
Die from collisions with deere 200 times
more than we'd.
Well it's two.
It's 2 million car accidents or one
point 5 million car accidents in this
country every year with dear one point 5
million.
And I think the number of people that
dies like 200.
Does that make sense?
But either way.
One point 5 million on 100 percent sure
of that.
It says leads to about 200 human deaths
in one point.
$1,000,000,000
in property damage.
Seen them property damage thing.
So what about the deer's life?
Because that not worth money.
You son of a bitch.
Oh,
you put money on life.
I'm a killer.
I turned into a werewolf that bear video
I think you posted the other day.
Oh yeah.
That's so fucked up.
Not good.
That makes me want to buy a gun just for
that.
Not good.
There's a lot of not good lately.
What did you see?
The mountain lion one for the mountain
lion was falling.
The guy around trying to figure out
whether or not it should jack.
I'm so not good.
Big ass old cat.
It's a big fucking cat and it's looking
at them.
I don't know if it's an old cat,
but I mean it's.
It's a mature cat.
Big cat.
Did he do it?
He should have done and that sits like
you kind of walked away and I thought
you're not supposed to.
You're not supposed to walk back,
but you have to be careful and
challenging it.
You're not supposed to look at it in the
eyes because it might.
It might instill a primal rage in that
fucking murderers predator where it just
decides to fuck you up.
It's hard to say what you're supposed to
do and what you're not supposed to do
because I've heard people say that you
should talk loud and I've heard people
say that you should just walk away,
jiggle your car keys.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't think you can predict.
Just like you can't predict like a
regular cat.
You'll get how many people have
different kinds of cats,
like you have different cats that I
have.
We all have different cats and I've had
a bunch of the same kind of cats.
They behave different.
They just all fucking animals are
different,
man.
You can run across one wolf that wants
to fuck you up and you could walk.
Well you can come across another wolf
that doesn't want to have anything to do
with you and wants to stay in the
background and move away from you.
So it's entirely possible that this guy
just ran across a cat that was thinking
about eating a person.
What would he have been able to kill
this and had been okay.
Like,
oh man.
Self defense.
Yeah.
If he had a weapon,
but I don't think he had a weapon.
I don't think he had anything like this.
This isn't.
Okay.
You couldn't have just killed it because
it's near them.
You would have to make a judgment call
and you'd have to be able to support
that judgment call.
Like if someone was out there,
right?
So if you were a bow hunter and you have
an a stare down with this mountain lion,
you have to be absolutely sure that
you've exhausted.
Yeah,
all of the possibilities.
But there's a fine line,
right?
Is like you want to,
you want to be able to preserve your own
life.
You want to make sure that you're okay,
but you also want to you,
if you're going to kill this thing,
you want to be right about it.
So you have to figure out what is that.
When you may hit that switch.
So do you hold onto the arrow and you
hold your bone front of that cat.
Like right there.
I gotta be honest with you.
I might shoot that fucking cat.
The cat is 15 feet away from him and
this guy got away with it,
but he didn't have to and now the cat's
moving in on him at 15 feet away.
The problem is once this thing jumps on
you,
you don't have a fucking chance.
And once it realizes how weak you really
are because you look way bigger than it,
you're standing like right there.
That cat's dead right there.
Broadside.
That's 15 feet away from.
I'm drawn an arrow back and I'm getting
rid of that cat.
I can't take that chance.
I'm not going to die.
I'm not going to die because I don't
want it to die.
I don't want to kill it,
but I don't want it to kill me for sure.
And this is an animal that is absolutely
stocking a person.
It's trying to figure out whether or not
it can do it.
Now,
in this guy's case,
he got lucky.
He talked enough.
He maybe he was a bigger guy.
Maybe the cat just didn't feel like it
was worth it.
I'd been throwing rocks.
Maybe.
Maybe the rocks would make it charge.
If you don't know,
man,
you don't know.
That's the problem.
If someone can tell you if,
uh,
the,
the general rule of thumb is if a bear
attacks you play dead.
But if a cougar attacks you fight back.
Where was this app by the way?
I think he was on his bike so he had his
bike in between them.
So maybe that's good.
Use it as like a little shield or
something.
Fuck yeah,
I'd be taking those tires off.
I'd beat that fucking thing to death.
I'd be scared as fuck right here to.
This guy is so cool about this.
Unbelievable.
There's a mountain lion right here.
I mean folks were free.
People listening.
It's on a trail.
This thing is 15 feet in front of them
right in front of me.
Oh yeah.
That's 15 feet in front of him,
right?
I mean maybe 20.
And he says this helmet on.
Whatever that thing's bite your face
off.
This is a nice time to own a gun.
Right here is nice.
You go,
hey man.
Hey man.
Check this out.
Boom.
Fuck you.
I don't know what I would've done if I
was.
If you have a gun,
you shoot it the ground.
You just just go,
bitch.
Oh,
he's moving towards it.
It's cute.
I might say to you,
I might.
He's backing up.
I might go crazy and see if I could
scare them off here.
That's probably what I would be doing.
I'd be screaming at it more.
Be dead.
Yeah,
most likely.
Let's be honest.
He'd be wheezing.
Delicious.
You lit a cigarette up.
Maybe he'd run away.
Yeah,
I would use fire cigarette smoking
house.
I would probably do that.
I'd probably like if I had my lighter
and light my shirt on fire or something
like that.
There was an old man in Canada just a
couple of years ago,
killed one with a knife.
He got attacked by a mountain lion and
you're 60 years old.
He's fighting off and cut its neck
fighting to the death with a monster
jumps out clause.
A hold of them.
Yeah.
I think mountain lions for just for the
record.
I think mountain lions are fucking
awesome.
I'm a big fan of mountain lions.
There's a lot of the people that are
animal rights activists,
they might hear this and say,
what about the person?
The person shouldn't be there.
That's the lion's home.
A persons in the lion's home.
Let's be honest folks.
There's people that are beautiful.
They produced poetry,
they write songs,
they make movies,
they love you.
They take you out to dinner,
they're your friend.
You can count on them.
They offer emotional support.
Mountain lions don't give you any of
that shit.
So when it comes,
when it comes to.
I know why I said poetry,
I believe I agree with everything I said
up to poetry,
but it comes to who do I like more?
Mountain lion or that guy on the bike.
I don't even know that guy on the bike.
I love him.
Give him a hug.
I shoot that fucking thing.
If I was nearby creepy ass predator cat,
it would be cool to have a full
simulation.
Like you can be like,
all right,
I'm going to see what happens if I went
up to it as if it was a normal cat,
like kind of like grizzly man style.
You just see red screen.
Yeah,
but if you could try everything.
Like now I'm ready.
Tried through mushu.
It'd be like a lawnmower.
Hit your face spray all over the screen.
I just wonder like if there was like
that kind of calming approach or
anything.
No,
no,
no.
What are you the grizzly man?
Hey mr.
It's going to be okay.
He must just chocolate.
I remember there's a scene,
the grizzly man where uh,
the bear took a shit and he's like,
this came out of this.
Came out of her butt touching.
I feel like I'm touching inside of her.
Came out of her,
but I get his hands on bear shit.
I wish there could be a sequel to that
movie so bad.
Like bob ross could plAy it.
Or here's the thing.
It
wasn't a sequel,
but that guy made I think more than a
hundred hours of footage.
He had a,
an entire show that they did on one of
the reality tv channels were.
It was a grizzly man show where it was
like they edited a lot of his last
footage and it was really fascinating
because as misguided as this guy was who
was definitely misguided and he
definitely had some issues for sure.
He really
did love bears and he was really
passionate about bears and he was
passionate about describing various
aspects of their behavior and it was
really interesting and he got some
fucking bad ass footage,
man.
He got some incredible footage like
really close up footage of bears
fighting.
He got footage of bears coming right up
to him and say like literally sniffing
his hand and running away.
He got footage of wild fox is becoming
his friend,
like hanging around his camp and he
would feed them and hang out with them.
They'd steal his hat.
He got amazing footage,
so if you look at the guy's just like a
wildlife photographer,
uk,
he's like one of the greatest of all
time in a way because what he did was
something that nobody was willing to do.
Go full screen on this motherfucker.
Can't put this on youtube.
Right.
Of course,
of course.
of course,
this is,
um,
if you haven't seen this,
this is two bears.
I think we did commentary on this during
the ice house chronicles because I was
talking about jitsu.
I was like,
he's got very good jujitsu.
like the way the big bear on top,
it's passing.
The other guy on the bottom is trying to
work the guard.
He's putting feet on the hips,
but the big bears using pressure.
He's like a old school like sallow.
He barrow like fucking rock solid
jujitsu.
Like this is what I'm looking at here.
And pooping,
he's,
oh yeah,
they shit the shit while they're going
to war.
But this is very much like jujitsu in a
lot of ways.
Man,
I'm.
When I'm,
when I'm watching this,
this is,
this is like rafael lovato.
This is that kind of jujitsu,
like super strong,
real technical pressure power to get on
top of you.
And they put the fucking clamped down on
you and you're dead.
Like this.
Bear is kind of doing that.
But the bottom bear got up.
Look at this.
He's game.
He's not as big,
but he's game.
They go to war,
the guy on the left is considerably
smaller if you see it,
you see how much smaller is like the one
on the right is like literally like 25
percent larger,
but the guy in the bottom is not given
up.
It's like marcello garcia,
rico rodriguez,
you motherfuckers don't even know she
steps training.
You see that video of a wrestler versus
a bodybuilder and like the same kind of
thing where the bodybuilders.
Super huge and you're like wrestling for
somebody.
there's a jujitsu.
When is pedro sAuer versus a
bodybuilder?
I'll maybe that's it.
Well pedro sauer I think.
Look up this pedro sauer s a u e r
versus I'm a bodybuilder and I think the
dude was like,
I want to say it was like 240 pounds and
pedro sauer was like 1:50
and he got in this like street fight
with this guy in a gym and this is back
in the day when like the gracie
challenges were going on.
She'll like that.
This is the guy he's fucking jacked.
And pedro sauer I believe is hixon
gracie linneage.
I apologize if I'm Wrong,
but either way,
he's a super respected.
I know he's great.
He's got a gracie ngayon,
super respected jujitsu instructor and
competitor,
so he's got this giant Bodybuilder in
front of him and he's like side kicking
him in the thigh.
This is so old school.
I
wish I knew what year this was,
but he keeps hitting him with his front
legs because even thought he's way small
than this guy and the bodybuilder yet to
move.
Now he tries to make his move and he
throws a punch,
but it didn't work in and pedro sauer
starts jacking him with punches and so
the guy takes him down.
So now when the guy takes him down,
pedro sauer immediately sweeps him,
mounts on them,
and that the dude rolled him over at
least one time,
but pedro didn't really take any damage.
You see how good like a real legit
brazilian jujitsu practitioner is at
protecting himself,
and then especially the fact that he's
wearing a gi,
which is even better because he can
really.
Even though the other guy is,
he's bare chested,
if pedro's we're an aggie,
he can control the guy because it's all,
it's grippy,
you know,
the allows you to hold onto a big
fucking sweaty gorilla like this guy.
So he eventually catches homeboy in an
arm bar.
It's not the same video I saw it,
but it's just pretty much idea.
Yeah.
I want to say this was like 95 or
something like that.
So he's holding onto the dude.
What does it say?
what does it say?
That guy was 92,
mr Utah.
So I thought I thought it was in
[inaudible] 92.
Well,
pedro sauer.
I think he's in Utah.
I think he's a salt lake city guy.
I'm pretty sure I might be wrong,
but in either way,
pedro sauer,
super respected,
very a very high level jujitsu
instructor.
A lot of blood here.
Man.
Who's got the blood?
Look at that.
Oh shit.
Armbar son.
I think he.
He made that dude's fucking nose explode
before your arm barred him.
Is that guys face a bloody mess?
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah,
there It is.
That's the blood.
Yeah.
He punched him in the nose and choke the
shit out of him and then took his.
Took his arm,
old school son,
but the difference in strength and size,
pretty substantial.
what did you say?
Mine was obviously one of those facebook
videos I guess who wins when you
progress wrestler versus a bodybuilder
in the bodybuilder was just this huge
monster bodybuilder and the rest are
just had no problem.
Just throwing them on the ground
constantly.
Just it was just wrestling.
I was an mma but it wasn't a pro
wrestler.
You said progress or was it just like.
Just like.
no,
like I'm not a progress wrestler.
Like a professional wrestler.
Like s like oh,
like someone is an expert.
Expert.
Yeah.
Progress was used to be real wrestlers,
like not that they're not now.
Now they're more real entertainers,
but they can wrestle.
Obviously brock lesnar can wrestle,
but the original days of progressing it
wasn't fake.
It is the weirdest thing.
That is the only sport that's a sport in
the fucking olympics,
but in the professional world it's fake.
And when I say fake,
I don't mean it disrespectfully.
I know,
joked around about progressing a lot of
progressing fans.
Got super butthurt.
Listen,
I absolutely respect the athletes and
their abilities and what they're doing.
I like to fuck with tony hinchcliffe
folks.
Okay.
It's fun.
He loves wrestling a little too much and
if you burned along with
that.
I'm so sorry,
but my honest feelings about pro
wrestling as I.
It disturbs me that guys who are so good
and women who are so good at wrestling
don't have a professional venue for it.
we're wrestling is so exciting on an
amateur level.
Whereas like tennis players have massive
opportunities.
Everybody else has massive
I mean,
I guess swimming doesn't,
but a lot of like big time sports have
these huge opportunities,
but what?
Swimming doesn't have his amateur
swimming and then fake swimming where
they're like rolling.
He's got jello.
He got the job.
all ladies and gentlemen,
Michael Phelps says doing joe out
tomorrow,
renelle low and he would have elton john
sunglasses on and a fucking chuck
liddell mohawk and he'd be doing the pro
wrestling version of swimming with go
pro swimming.
Yeah,
nick,
nick fucking.
What's his name?
The guy who runs a pro wrestling,
vince mcmahon,
fensick man,
he puts a bandanna on his neck and he
has a one of those mark spitz mustaches.
This is a new look,
and he just talks about pro swimming
for.
We're taking pro swimming the same place
we took pro wrestling.
Alex Jones,
Michael Michael Phelps is like,
fuck man.
You know,
uh,
I love wheaties as much as the next guy,
but I'm tired.
I'm tired of just living off sponsors.
I got to watch what I do.
I can't smoke weed.
This is Bullshit.
Why don't I have a professional venue?
Hey man,
if,
if fucking golf is in the olympics and
golfers make millions of dollars,
everybody got a damn swims,
you'll know how to swim.
Didn't erase your cousin when you were a
kid.
We all know how to swim,
right?
Okay,
let's make pro swimming.
Let's do this.
He gets together with vince mcmahon.
they have swimming.
that's good idea.
Like there's hoops that they guys don't
even care like it.
Espn launches new wwe vertical.
What?
What does that mean?
Was a vertical.
They're going to start covering wwe or
you hard right now.
No job.
You're whoa,
whoa.
Why would a sports thing,
and we decided to do that because they
don't need money.
I know it's entertainment,
but like the.
Well apparently these shows are doing
not so good because of the internet,
because of the different.
like if you're talking about like where
you get your news and your entertainment
and your coverage of different sports.
A lot of people turned to the internet.
Say if you had a studio,
okay,
and you had a studio in hollywood and
you said,
hey,
you know what?
I enjoy the ufc coverage.
I enjoy a bella tours coverage.
I enjoy all these different mixed
martial arts,
but I want to do my own new show and I'm
just going to put it on youtube and I'm
going to hire dean.
Thomas is essentially what dana white's
done with that.
Looking for a fight show.
What if someone comes along and says,
I'm going to do that with a cowboy
serone some fun,
colorful characters and a.
I'm going to have them talk about fights
every week.
Who is going to watch the espn show?
If you can watch brian stann,
dominic serone and,
or,
uh,
donald cerrone and cruz talk about
fights.
Who the fuck is going to watch anything
else?
I want to hear what they have to say.
I want to hear what donald has to say
about conor mcgregor.
I wanna hear with dominick.
Cruz has say about cody garbrandt.
I want to hear like what,
what these like super influential
fighters who were like some of those
interesting characters in the world.
I have to say you're not gonna be able
to recreate that with some talking head
that used to cover women's volleyball
and now he's covering mma and you know
last night,
blah blah blah.
Amanda nunez became the cleveland indian
women can mean,
you know,
he doesn't give a fuck.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He doesn't care.
You would,
you would watch the internet show,
right?
So if the internet was available on your
tv,
what's an espn gonna do.
And that's common man that's coming.
Bill burrs gonna have a fucking football
show on espn and everybody better shut
their mouth because it's bill burr
hasn't like if he does what he does on
his podcast,
I don't even follow the nfl,
but when he starts making fun of people
of the in the nfl and talking about fans
and stuff on his podcast,
it's hilarious if someone wises up and
gives bill burr some sort of a platform,
a gigantic platform reviewing football.
Oh my god,
everybody else has done carl because he
knows his shit too.
Like bill burr understands football.
Like when I listened to them like,
oh,
this guy is not just like a comedian
talking shit about stuff.
he actually understands football.
I can listen to them talk about
anything.
I love that dude.
He's an american treasure.
Fuck.
Yeah.
That's more like the delivery method has
outpaced.
Yes.
Content.
I guess it's eliminated the necessity of
a large studio.
Like a friend of mine was going to do
something on the internet recently and
he's like,
this group wants to pay me money to be,
you know,
to be associated with this.
And I go,
okay,
what are you going to do it on?
And he goes,
I'm going to do it on youtube and my
uncle,
uh,
why would you want to,
why would you want someone coming along
and being a part of that when you can
just do it yourself.
Like if you get.
I'm like,
if you get in bed with this person or
this group,
there's a media conglomerate,
you get a bed,
this media conglomerate with your
project that you're trying to launch
online,
you're going to be relieved as some of
the financial burden.
But in this case I was talking to a guy
is not hurting for money.
I'm like,
you're not talking about a substantial
investment.
What do you need?
You need a camera.
You need to an employee,
you need an upload place.
You need to send out.
You need something like youtube is
essentially free.
You just need a good internet
connection.
Good computers like the,
the price of entry is not exorbitant in
relationship to the potential.
But if you get involved with some sort
of a media conglomerate,
these guys,
all of these people are very smart.
All these people that are involved in
all these different networks,
they have existed for the longest time.
They are the old vampire versions of
hollywood like they've existed forever
and they've grown up in this and some of
them have come along in different
transitionary phase of the system,
but they realize right now the system is
in jeopardy.
It's in a very strange place because the
internet is slowly becoming more and
more prevalent in people's lives.
It's consuming more and more people's
entertainment time and it's becoming
more powerful and its abilities.
The ability that someone has today is
what you can create an edit on a
computer.
It's literally getting to the point
where I could make a movie with you and
you don't even have to be in it.
I can just decide I'm going to make
fucking slumber party 10 with jamie
vernon and slow.
Jamie vernon shows up aT the door with a
fucking pizza delivery outfit on and 15
skanky hose.
Just dive on his pecker and we make a
porn.
I mean,
this 100 percent possible.
That's the only like 10 years away from
now,
man,
and you're going to be able to stream
things online.
You're going to be able to create a film
with a regular laptop in a fucking phone
and it's going to look like a goddamn
movie.
People have probably already done it.
snapchat filters,
so there's a good example.
If you do it right now I can make a
movie.
Jamie I gay porn.
Exactly.
I read an article about what you're
talking about really that they used the
example of the new peewee herman movie
that he looks a little too young for
what he should be throughout the movie,
but they article describes how there's
this thing called what they're called
cgi facelifts and there's multiple
million dollar actors and actresses that
use teams of people or keep them at a
younger looking and in movies like.
Like whaT the did for benjamin button.
She made brad pitt stay younger.
Looking at like was strapping 22 year
old dude when he was really like 45.
That's just a filter.
You can tell the detail level is just
fogged out,
you know,
as a still frame.
It's a filter,
but he looks like that throughout the
whole movie.
So it's a separate video on that.
I think he's.
What he's saying is that this is a still
frame of the video.
Yeah.
And uh,
but there's just like.
I know what you're saying.
No,
no,
I was saying they're doing it through
movies and a rabbit.
This is the whole movie.
It's like this,
right?
Like,
is this an actual still friends?
As far as I know.
Yeah.
I looked.
Even snapchat has that one filter that
makes.
It's called the pretty filter or
beautiful filter.
It just pretty much does the same thing.
I kinda softens your face and gets rid
of the detail.
Well,
have you seen the real life filters that
they use in their.
They have this new thing that they've
invented where it's a film that they put
on your skin and it radically reduces
wrinkles.
Oh wow.
Like it's an invisible film.
It lasts 24 hours.
You put it on your skin and it's
waterproof and it radically reduces
wrinkles.
Have you seen this?
No,
I haven't seen it.
Cool.
Fucking weird thing to think about it.
We're going to bang some old lady's
dude.
Oh god,
100 percent for you.
Good.
You drink a loT of good with my 22 year
old.
Remember that time in austin?
Which one do you remember the time where
a lady sat next to you and started
kissing you and you were hammered?
You thought it was the wrong lady.
Do you remember that?
We've talked about that before.
The old lady,
old lady got deep into brian's face.
Mountain.
Brian's mouth was.
His eyes were closed the whole time.
Brown brian had a lovely lady with him.
And by the way,
this is a long,
long time ago.
Yeah.
Any parties currently invested in mr
brian red band.
Need not worry.
Many,
many,
many moons ago.
And uh,
this lovely young lady took off and
this,
uh,
this woman parked her broomstick and sat
down next to god like 70 years old.
No tea,
no bullshit.
At least 60,
At least 60.
And she just attacked me out of nowhere.
Plopped down next year.
Put her hand on your chest.
You smiled and looked over with your
eyes closed.
And she dove in for The kiss and you
thought you were kissing the other girl
and then you realized in the middle it
was like,
oh,
it's like there's a horror movie where
that happens.
Where the guys making out with the girl
and her face falls apart.
You realize that she's a monster.
Isn't there a horror movie like that?
Well,
in part of Indiana jones where they
opened up the chest and that nazis face
melts.
Kind of.
Yeah,
it's like that.
But there was a movie where a guy was
making out with a girl and I want to say
like her hair started falling out or
something like that was god damn it.
What movie was it?
Oh,
the shining is this shining.
remember Jack Nicholson goes into one of
those mysterious rooms and he starts
making out with this woman and her skin
starts falling off exactly what it is.
IT's exactly what it is.
Oh my god.
Find that scene.
Let's end this podcast and you recorded
the whole thing on video and you thought
you were doing me a favor by deleting
it.
I would love to have seen that.
I know I fucked up.
I was trying to protect her brother.
It was dark.
It was dark shit.
I don't even think she had teeth.
She was a monster.
I was right out of the swamps.
She came out of swamps.
You can't show it.
But for us,
can we see it where nobody else sees it?
Put it on,
make sure that nobody sees it,
which just showed you and nobody can see
it.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
So she's super,
super hot in that 19 seventies.
I don't know how to work out hot,
which is great for like eight years.
Nice area.
Look,
girls,
girls have that hot for eight years,
right around 26.
It starts to go,
hey.
Um,
we're not really making the same amount
of hormones anymore.
And you don't want to play soccer.
Oh,
what's going on with his body like that?
Bush full bush,
bush,
bush.
Uh,
which by the way,
I don't mind.
It doesn't bother me at all.
It was Jack Nicholson doesn't know what
to do.
She's touching him.
Oh shit.
I don't remember this scene.
and I definitely don't remember the
scene being this long.
I remember it being like real short.
I feel like I watched this recently and
don't remember the scene in the movie.
I remember it happened for sure.
Which is why I brought it up,
but I don't remember it.
Like I'm looking at it.
This all seems super new to me.
So he starts making out with her.
she's got to fly the house,
squats,
go to go to the gym,
bitch.
Oh,
oh.
So he's kissing her and in the middle of
kissing her,
I was like,
oh,
he's having such a good time.
You could see that she looks a little
bony.
Yeah,
something's not right.
Something's wrong.
Then he opens his eyes and he opens his
eyes and you realize she's an old lady.
His eyes go wide open.
He can't even enjoy it.
He's a hater.
Oh,
she's got turns.
Moly.
Caesar in the mirror and her back in the
mirror is covered with welts and his
little kid starts seizure.
And now she's in the tub and he's
backing up.
She's decaying.
She's laughing and coming towards him.
Holy shit,
this is a good movie.
It's like an old lady from kingpin.
See,
here's my point.
Where the fuck are these movies?
Man?
This is my kind of movie.
I like horror movies.
I'm a huge fan.
I like monster movies.
I like horror movies.
Doesn't have to be real.
I know it's not real.
I haven't seen him,
but I heard that movie.
Green room is supposed to be pretty
interesting.
What's that?
There's a new one called a where the
blind man can't see it.
It looks pretty intense too.
I forgoT.
Don't,
don't talk or don't whisper.
How could that be as good as this green
room story of louie anderson?
Derek,
really high for gay.
Liliana
sends a wonderful gentlemen.
I love him.
I think he's a hilarious comedian.
Let's find this bitch.
Let's bring it home.
Thank you everybody for the happy
birthday wishes.
Yeah.
Appreciate the fuck out of it.
Oh a while.
This is ending.
We haven't entered it yet.
Hold on.
Before we end it,
don't end it.
I'm going to get a.
I've been doing this thing on instagram.
You know,
instagram has that.
Uh,
yeah.
The storage thing,
so I've been doing the instagram story,
so if you listen to the podcasts,
new work,
what's going on with your instagram
story?
Bruce?
I'll show you what's going on.
My instagram story.
Motherfucker.
Shit him.
It splits around.
Whoops.
That's the flash.
I don't want the flush.
This
is my life at 49.
One more.
Oh god damn.
It just took a picture of my council.
I'm trying to get this light off.
How do I get this light off the pitcher?
That lightning bolts.
I know.
We Just want to make sure it's all
right.
Here it goes.
Ladies and gentLemen,
just had a wonderful podcast with brian
red band and jamie will see you soon.
AlrighT,
bye.
Bye.